Messieurs, bonsoir. Nous vous recevons
pour une chaîne internet qui s'appelle
Syerview. Nous sommes en direct. Est-ce
que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ?
Oui, je m'appelle Philippe Biwix. Je
suis ingénieur. Je m'intéresse depuis
une quinzaine d'années aux questions de
consommation de ressources et à tout ce
qui est technologie et développement
durable. disait-on il y a 15 ans,
maintenant on parle plutôt de
transition.
Nicolas Millant, je suis aussi ingénieur
et moi je m'intéresse au sujet de
énergie et transport depuis aussi une
petite quinzaine d'années et je suis
aussi conseiller scientifique avec
France Stratégie. Je fais partie d'un
singonoclast
et l'association pour l'étude du PIC
pétrolier.
Donc on a décidé de vous faire revenir
ce soir pour nous parler de ces fameuses
questions d'énergie, de ces fameuses
questions de transition écologique
énergétique et tout le le bullshit world
qui va avec.
Est-ce qu'on est en ce moment à l'air
des amiches quand on n'est pas d'accord
avec le président de la République
Philippe Bwix ?
Alors notre président s effectivement un
petit peu lâché. On a senti que c'était
euh c'est son péché mignon en fait hein,
le la tech française hein. Donc ça il
faut se rappeler quand même que le son
show au consumer show de Las Vegas avait
l'avait lancé dans la dans la campagne
présidentielle ou la précampagne
présidentielle. Donc on a senti que
c'est un peu lâché. Peut-être que voilà
est-ce que est-ce qu'il a utilisé cette
expression la lampe à huile et à mich à
dessin ou est-ce que ou est-ce que le
ces mots ont dépassé sa pensée ? J'en
sais rien. Ce qui est certain, c'est
qu'effectivement, on sent quand même que
le clivage se tend. D'ailleurs, il
dépasse, je pense, les questions de
parti politique traditionnel
sur cette question du progrès. Le mot
progrès d'ailleurs est en train de
revenir. Il avait été il avait été
chassé par le mot innovation
technologique et on recommence à poser
la question du progrès. Progrès
technologique. Est-ce que le progrès ?
Et donc voilà, c'est finalement
effectivement le le 5G ou le ou le
retour à la bougie. Donc c'est en gros
il faut foncer dans la course en avant
technologique sinon euh sinon on est
forcément rétrograde. Voilà et c'est le
débat dans lequel on essaie de de nous
enfermer aujourd'hui. Alors
qu'évidemment le cette question de la 5G
pourquoi est-ce que pourquoi est-ce que
le débat est aussi virulent finalement
en ce moment alors qu'il aurait il a pas
été autant sur les questions de je sais
pas de nanotechnologie de 4G ou de 3G
même peut-être il y a quelques on va
dire il y a une décennie parce que je
pense que voilà entre-temps il y a eu on
a un petit peu mûri le sujet de de des
coûts bénéfices dirait les économistes
entre entre le toute nouvelle
technologie entre le ce que ça va
pouvoir apporter est-ce que ça va
pouvoir est-ce ce que ça va coûter d'un
point de vue environnemental parce que
toute technologie coûte et voilà
aujourd'hui la 5G bah elle coche toutes
les cases de on sait ce que ça va coûter
ou enfin en tout cas on présume et par
contre on voit pas très bien ce que ça
va rapporter d'un point de vue
environnemental malgré toutes les
superbes annonces.
C'est quoi les superbes annonces ?
Alors on en a de de plusieurs sortes.
Alors peut-être on pourrait en évacuer
une première qui est assez sympathique
qui est la question de la la chirurgie à
distance. la téléchirurgie, souvent ça
qui est mis en avant sur les par les
commentateurs. Alors, c'est la
possibilité d'avoir grâce à en fait à un
temps de latence très court donc en fait
voilà de l'ordre du microseconde donc un
réseau qui est beaucoup plus rapide on
va dire que le réseau 4G donc c'est la
possibilité du coup d'avoir un
chirurgien à un bout du monde et puis
une opération de l'autre. Alors, c'est
formidable. Sauf qu'on comprend pas très
bien pourquoi pour ça, il faudrait
tartiner le le pays de de 5G puisque'en
fait, on va pas se faire opérer à cœur
ouvert par un super spécialiste hawaen
dans une camionnette de la RS dans un
village de France. Si on se fait opérer,
on va être pris en charge. Il y aura un
anesthésiste qui sera quand même lui pas
à distance. Il y aura forcément des
infirmiers, des infirmières, un
accompagnement. Donc on va rejoindre un
hôpital et quand bien même le chirurgien
serait loin, bah en fait en réalité euh
il y a juste à fibrer en connecter en
fibre l'hôpital et puis on arrivera à
faire ça tranquillement. Donc c'est un
très mauvais argument mais qui est
souvent utilisé et d'ailleurs peut-être
on reviendra sur les questions de de de
gestion de la crise sanitaire peut-être
aussi mais c'est que voilà quand on a un
truc à faire passer pas mal d'utiliser
soit l'argument sécuritaire soit
l'argument sanitaire ou médical quoi.
C'estd qu'on serait des monstres si on
refusait que demain des gens puissent
profiter de cette formidable
téléchirurgie. Voilà [grognement] ça
c'est le premier argument. Ensuite il y
en a plusieurs autres. Alors, il y a la
il y a la voiture autonome, il y a la
smart city, l'internet des objets et il
y a l'industrie 4.0, on va dire. Grosso
modo, voilà. Donc, si on développait pas
5G, on va se faire vassaliser par les
autres pays parce qu'en fait voilà,
l'industrie va se barrer parce que en
gros le datas, c'est les autoroutes du
futur. Donc, on s'installe pas dans une
on s'installe pas dans un pays qui a pas
les autoroutes quoi. Voilà. Alors, si on
les prend un par un pour, [grognement]
bon, c'est pas j'essaie de pas faire
trop long, mais la voiture autonome donc
elle utilise aussi le le le temps de
latence et surtout et la capacité à à
échanger des données massivement entre
le entre le le réseau et puis le le
terminal ou les terminaux. Donc la
voiture autonome, son premier sujet,
c'est d'abord que
est-ce qu'elle a une quelconque
viabilité économique avant même d'avoir
atteint sa sa solution technique, c'est
la voiture autonome de niveau 4 ou 5,
l'autonomie 4 ou 5, c'est-à-dire celle
où on peut vraiment la laisser en
autonomie totale sans sans être
constamment tout près du volant pour
pour reprendre la main. Mais je pense
que tu pourras en parler un petit peu
Nicolas.
Donc bon, par exemple Carlos Tavarez, le
le patron de PSA, disait "La voiture
autonome, ceux qui pourront se la payer,
ils sont déjà assis sur la banquette
arrière." Donc en fait, il y a une
question de de pertinence économique
dans le déploiement.
Euh
la deuxième chose, c'est l'internet des
objets ou la smart city. Alors, la smart
city, il y a quelques exemples
d'économie environnementale qu'on
pourrait faire du type "lesbelles vont
venir réclamer de se faire vider
seulement quand elles sont pleines."
Donc, on va économiser des tours de
camion. Bon, OK, peut-être un peu, j'en
sais rien. À part ça, la Smart City,
personne sait trop ce que ce que ça veut
dire. L'internet des objets, bah ça va
être le réfrigérateur qui fait ses
courses tout seul. Ça va être les
objets, les wearbles, les voilà un
certain nombre de de choses possibles.
Là, c'est pareil, on voit pas très bien
le les bénéfices environnementaux et le
en tout cas le voilà, il y a il y a en
tout cas, on peut contester le monde que
ça que ça promet. Et puis l'industrie
4.0, ben c'est la la possibilité de dire
voilà, je vais suivre plein de de pièces
différentes, je vais pouvoir dans une
usine extrêmement mécanisée, automatisé.
Euh bon, faut savoir que voilà, dans une
voiture doit y avoir un million de
pièces différentes, donc ça c'est
compliqué à suivre même si elles
arrivent pas toutes, elles arrivent sous
forme de sous-système dans les dans les
usines. Bah là, c'est un peu comme
l'intériochirurgie, c'est-à-dire que si
une antenne 3G de de faible portée,
celles qui ont le gros débit, c'est de
l'ordre de 300 m. Donc bah si vous avez
une usine qui fait 300 m de large par 1
km de long, vous avez besoin de trois
antennes, vous avez couvert votre usine,
vous pouvez faire de la 4G dans votre
usine et à nouveau, il y a pas besoin de
tartiner tout le pays pour ça quoi.
Voilà, donc voilà à peu près les usages
aujourd'hui qui sont promis. On peut en
rajouter un ou deux autres sur tout ce
qui est débit massif, donc capacité de
calcul déporté. On peut imaginer tout ce
qui est réalité virtuelle, tout ce qui
est réalité augmentée. Voilà, on peut
imaginer que dans le futur, on aura je
sais pas quoi, les collégiens qui
pourront chausser un casque de réalité
virtuelle et rester à la maison,
protéger des virus et faire l'école
numérique qui est tellement formidable
par ailleurs, nous dit-on. Euh ou
[grognement] alors on sera tous avec
notre casque et notre masque dans la rue
et comme on aura pas réussi à embellir
la ville et bien on aura en fait voilà,
on aura plein de choses qui nous
augmenteront la réalité euh de manière
virtuelle.
Nicolas Mayant, la 5G, les voitures
autonomes, la Smart City,
bah les voitures autonomes, c'est un
sujet c'est un sujet intéressant. Ce
qu'on retrouve finalement avec la 5G les
amis, c'est le débat qu'on a en France
où soit c'est tout blanc, soit c'est
tout noir.
C'est un peu comme avec la géopolitique,
non ? Et la guerre, c'est soit vous êtes
avec nous, soit vous êtes contre nous.
Voilà, par exemple tous les débats sur
l'énergie et l'environnement, c'est soit
c'est du tout nucléaire, soit c'est du
tout renouvelable. Entre les deux, ça
n'existe pas. Le débat sur la voiture,
c'est soit c'est diesel, soit c'est
électrique, mais entre les deux, ça
n'existe pas. Et et ça c'est la raison
pour laquelle en fait le sujet n'avance
pas depuis 20 ans et que la transition
énergétique, je le dis souvent, c'est
vraiment la fake news du siècle
puisqu'on empile les choses, on empile
les technologies mais on ne on ne
remplace pas les choses. Alors la
voiture autonome et je suis d'accord
avec Philippe, la première question
qu'on doit se poser, c'est pas toujours
ce débat de technologie, c'est le débat
de l'usage. On fait quoi avec ? Alors la
voiture autonome, ce qui est génial, tu
comprends, c'est que en ville, tu vas
pouvoir prendre un Uber et comme il y a
pas le chauffeur, il va te coûter trois
fois moins cher. Tu vas quand même le
payer à la NPE parce que il faut quand
même qu'il fasse quelque chose. Et comme
il va coûter trois fois moins cher, ben
tu vas pouvoir l'utiliser tout le temps.
Sauf que ça, qu'est-ce que ça fait ? Un
effet rebond. On l'a vu avec Uber, on a
un meilleur service au même prix, on
l'utilise beaucoup plus. Donc Uber, ça
fait que les gens prennent beaucoup plus
la voiture individuelle qu'avant. Avant,
ils prenaient le transport en commun, le
vélo, la marche. Maintenant, ils
prennent Uber. Tout le monde a un
chauffeur. Avant les chauffeurs c'était
que les patrons du CAC 40. Maintenant
tout le monde a un chauffeur. Et et
l'autre problème de la voiture autonome,
c'est qu'en fait en ville, le problème
c'est pas la voiture diesel, la voiture
électrique machin, c'est la voiture tout
court. Donc quand elle sera autonome, ce
sera toujours un problème. Les bouchons,
c'est parce que quand on va au travail,
les voitures sont remplies par 1,1
personnes. Bon, est-ce que quand on va
mettre des voitures avec zéro personnes,
est-ce que ça va résoudre le problème ?
il y a aucune chance que ça résolve le
problème. Le seul intérêt éventuel de
cette voiture autonome, c'est euh quand
on est quand on est à la campagne, qu'on
n' pas de transport en commun, qu'on
peut pas conduire, mobilité réduite et
là effectivement on pourrait avoir cette
voiture qui vient vous chercher, qui
coûte moins cher, donc plus accessible
parce qu'elle est partagée. Sauf qu'il
faut qu'elle soit électrique. Si on est
à la campagne, ça va faire des longues
distances, on va peut-être avoir des
problèmes d'autonomie. Et comme dit
Philippe, est-ce que juste pour cet
usage qui pourrait éventuellement faire
du sens, on va aller mettre 3 millions
de de voitures 3 millions 30 millions de
voitures autonomes ? J'avais fait un
petit calcul marrant pour parce qu'on
dit "Oui, mais la voiture autonome c'est
génial parce que tu comprends 85 % des
accidents c'est à cause de l'homme."
Je me suis déjà toujours posé la
question de les 15 % restants, c'était
la faute de qui ?
Et donc en fait les accidents en ville,
c'est 700 morts par an sur 3000. Donc on
va aller mettre et pour qu'il y ait
économiser ces 700 morts, il faut que
toutes les voitures soient autonomes.
Donc pendant 15 ans, on change les
bagnoles et en 2050, on espère qu'il y
en ait 30 millions d'autonomes. Et là
une vie, c'est une vie, c'est important
aussi cette
et là on va économiser 700000 morts et
que je ramène
700000 morts
pardon 700 morts 700 morts à comparer au
entre 50 et 70000 morts par an lié à la
pollution atmosphérique. Donc ça la
pollution atmosphérique on peut le faire
tout de suite, c'est facile. on prend
les véhicules polluants, on les sort des
villes, voilà, ça va vite. Non, mais on
va on va aller mettre des voitures
autonomes pour tout le monde pour que
peut-être dans 20 ans, on économise 700
700 700 mois. Sachant que dans 20 ans
vraisemblablement avec les contraintes
énergétiques, on va devoir se passer des
voitures quand on peut le faire et a
priori là, on peut bien le faire, c'est
en ville.
Philippe,
il y a deux mots sur lesquels je voulais
réagir. Il y avait le il y a la question
effectivement de ces usages de la
voiture autonome et puis a la question
de l'empilement que tu as mentionné.
Alors sur les usages, ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est qu'en fait il y a
potentiellement une multiplicité
d'usages de la voiture autonome. La
voiture autonome, on va dire à la Jérémy
Rifkin, très partageuse, très partagée
où on s'est dépouillé de la propriété et
finalement du coup avec le numérique, je
convoque effectivement mon chauffeur et
je vais venir finalement partager ma
voiture sur un trajet donné et puis aura
passer son temps à monter, descendre
finalement et et la voiture va tourner
pendant la journée et cetera. Donc ça,
celle-là, elle est convoquée justement
pour des questions de d'avantage
environnemental parce qu'il y aurait
moins de voiture, du coup, il y aurait
moins de bouchon et cetera et cetera.
Puis a un autre type de voiture autonome
qui est celle quand même que les
constructeurs préféreraient, c'est la
voiture autonome bureau mobile de papa
et maman. C'estàd qu'en fait, il y a
toujours une propriété et en fait
simplement je vais pouvoir monter dans
ma voiture le matin à 7h ou 7h15.
J'habite un peu loin et fait rebond.
D'ailleurs, je peux me permettre
d'habiter plus loin parce que je vais
pouvoir travailler dans dans la voiture
qui conduit toute seule. Et donc en
fait, on voit c'est toujours c'est toute
l'histoire de la technologie, c'est que
la technologie elle elle coûte quelque
chose. Alors après, elle peut coûter de
moins en moins cher sil y a vraiment des
effets d'échelle, s'il y a un
déploiement massif, s'il y a des gains
de productivité et cetera. Mais la
technologie, elle remplace du travail
humain et donc soit elle remplace du
travail humain rémunéré, c'est-à-dire
c'était le chauffeur de taxi. Et là, on
peut se dire qu'effectivement, il y a
éventuellement une pertinence au sens
pertinence économique parce que je me
paye la technologie mais je paye plus le
je paye plus la main d'œuvre, soit je
remplace du travail non rémunéré qui
était papa et maman qui ou maman qui
conduisent la voiture et à ce moment-là,
bah c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
trouver une pertinence sur le modèle
économique. Donc du coup l'avènement de
cette voiture autonome. Alors il faut
aussi se dire que du coup pour qu'elle
soit autonome et qu'elle soit autonome
partout, faudrait de la 5G partout. Je
rappelle qu'on a déjà du mal à faire de
la 4G partout ou la 3G partout. Donc la
5G partout, je sais pas
la fibre partout d'ailleurs.
Donc je sais pas quand est-ce que peut
être le voilà cette échéance. Puis c'est
plus ce que tu mentionnais Nicolas,
c'est-à-dire de dire d'abord il faut que
les voitures soient dispo puis ensuite
queil y ait une dizaine ou une quinzaine
d'années de remplacement du parc. Tout
ça ça nous amène, j'en sais rien, en
2050 2060. Et en face de ça, alors du
coup, il y aura d'autres challenges en
2050 60 mais en face de ça, les coûts
euh environnementaux
de la 5G à l'instant tout de suite
maintenant quand on les déploie, ceuxl
ils sont des 2020 ou 2021. Alors, quels
sont-ils entre autres ? Bah, c'est
justement on a cette notion
d'empilement, c'est-à-dire que on entend
avec quand même une mauvaise foi
hallucinante le fait que la 5G est
beaucoup plus efficace d'un point de vue
environnemental.
comprendre quoi. On a des antennes qui
consomment plus peut-être de l'ordre de
deux à tr fois plus mais on n'est pas
vraiment sûr parce que d'ailleurs les
chinois coupe leurs antennes la nuit.
Oui. Alors ça alors effectivement les
déploiements qu'il y a en Chine qu' a eu
en Chine aujourd'hui ou en Corée sont
les expérimentations principales
il y a il y a deux phénomènes. Alors le
fait que ça coupe la nuit ça a l'air
d'être normal. C'est plutôt en fait
justement une logique de d'optimisation
des équipements qui se mettent en veille
quand ils sont pas sollicités. Bon donc
c'est pas forcément complètement un
signal de de désespérance. Le signal de
désespérance, c'est que un certain
nombre d'opérateurs euh ont obtenu enfin
les opérateurs on ont réclamé et obtenu
en Chine des subventions euh pour
justement la consommation euh
énergétique électrique supplémentaire
parce qu'en fait en face il y a pas
vraiment de revenu parce que justement
c'est qui qui est capable de payer ce
surplus de de d'équipement ? C'est soit
effectivement des consommateurs qui vont
dire bah j'ai un forfait 5G, c'est
génial, je peux télécharger mon film en
2 secondes plutôt qu'en 1 minute 30 ou
ou plutôt quand je suis à la maison sur
le wifi. Est-ce que ça combien ça vaut
d'euros dans un forfait ce trucl ? Bah
ça dépend des pays sans doute et c'est
peut-être pas grand-chose. Et puis tous
les usages industriels qu'on a mentionné
tout à l'heure, bah ceuxlà c'est Pinots
sont revenus pendant un certain temps.
Donc il y a un vrai problème d'équation
économique chez les opérateurs télécom.
Ceux qui sont intéressés, ce sont les
constructeurs, c'està-dire en gros, il y
en a cinq, hein, Ericson, Nokia et puis
ZTE, Huawei en Chine et puis Samsung.
Voilà. Donc eux, ils ont un intérêt
effectivement à être dans cette logique
de de déploiement d'équipement et les
opérateurs font à moitié grismin.
C'est-à-dire que c'est un peu le dilemme
du prisonnier. C'est si si personne y
allait, ils seraiit peut-être
potentiellement contents de pas y aller,
mais ils peuvent pas être celui qui dit
"Ah mais est-ce qu'il faut vraiment y
aller Bon, Martin Big a tenté une sorte
de de moratoire de quelques mois dis
"Ah, peut-être c'est pas le bon moment,
il s'est fait jeter par tous les
autres." Enfin, en tout cas, il y avait
bon d'autres forces politicoéconomiques
qui ont été convoquées pour soutenir la
5G. On va dire ça comme ça. Donc donc il
y a pas l'équation économique
aujourd'hui, elle est loin d'être
claire. Voilà. Et l'équation
énergétique, donc j'y reviens, pardon,
j'ai fait une circonvolution, c'est que
voilà, c'est beaucoup plus efficace
cette antenne 5G. euh elle va
transporter beaucoup plus de données en
consommant un peu plus d'énergie. Donc
globalement par octé transporté, par
unité d'énergie, c'est vachement mieux.
C'est peut-être on sait pas exactement
mais allez j'en sais rien, 10 fois plus
efficace. On sait pas parce que les
opérateurs savent pas non plus, enfin
les constructeurs savent pas non plus.
Ça dépendra aussi des stratégies de
déploiement des réseaux. On on joue en
fait sur le 5G, c'est la force de la 5G
d'ailleurs entre des grand des des
antennes à longue portée plutôt des
billés, des petites antennes, les small
cell qui sont plutôt à 300 m de portée
qui a qui ont un grand débit et en
jouant sur ces deux trucs là, on a à la
fois la couverture, la pénétration dans
les bâtiments et le débit. Bref, donc du
coup c'est beaucoup plus efficace, sauf
que en face de ça, il y a évidemment
deux choses. La première, c'est qu'on
empile, c'est-à-dire qu'on quand on
installe le réseau 5G, ben on l'installe
par-dessus le réseau 4G, 3G. 2G puisque
euh ils ont même le 2G n'a pas n'a pas
été démonté pour différentes raisons.
Donc on est sûr que ça va consommer
forcément plus. On va empiler combien de
fois plus ? Il y a un peu débat, ça
dépendra de ce qu'on déploera
effectivement et du mix qui sera fait
par les différents opérateurs et surtout
bah en fait oui ça va être bien plus
efficace par par unité transportée mais
il va y avoir ce satanné effet rebond et
là ça sera pas un effet rebond j'habite
à 20 km ou le d'habiter à 10 km c'est
l'effet rebond plus c'est-à-dire une
multiplication peut-être par on n sait
trop rien 5 10 15 100000 on parle même
de de ces chiffres là c'est pas très dur
à faire dans le numéro qu'on a déjà fait
hein les données qu'on échange, les
données qu'on stock aujourd'hui, elles
doublent tous les 18 à 24 mois. Donc
multiplié par 1000, vous ferez le
calcul, ça dure pas très très longtemps
avec les puissances de 2, ça se fait
assez bien et on peut voilà convoquer
les exponentiels que maintenant tout le
monde connaît bien depuis les crises
sanitaire quand on multiplie par de tous
les 3 jours ou tous les 5 jours le
nombre de le nombre de [grognement] cas,
ça finit par faire très très mal, très
très vite et ben ça marche pareil.
Voilà,
on va reparler de la crise sanitaire un
peu plus tard. Nicolas Mayon, est-ce que
vous pouvez nous parler de ce fameux
plan hydrogène ? Ah, [grognement]
l'hydrogène. Moi, j'ai j'ai commencé à
quand j'ai commencé ma carrière comme
consultant en 2006, j'ai bossé sur un
projet sur les moteurs électriques dans
les roues des voitures. C'est comme ça
que je suis un peu tombé dans la voiture
électrique. Et j'ai fait une réunion
chez chez Peugeot où j'ai rencontré le
grand patron des moteurs et des boîtes
et on a parlé d'hydrogène. Et la phrase
qui m'a dite à l'époque, c'est une
phrase qui doit être traduite en
anglais, qui marche mieux en anglais,
mais je vais le traduire en français.
Hydrogen has a great future and always
will have. En gros, il m'a dit quand
j'ai commencé ma carrière il y a 40 ans,
l'hydrogène c'était pendant 40 ans et
aujourd'hui c'est toujours le cas. Donc
la France aime qui aime beaucoup
l'hydrogène pour d'autres raisons que
l'Allemagne d'ailleurs. L'Allemagne
nucléaire, c'est ça.
Voilà, parce qu'on peut faire ça. Alors
à une époque quand on faisait de la 4e
génération, il était question de faire
de de du craquage à haute température de
l'hydrogène et c'était une façon
efficace de le produire. Bon, sauf que
la 4e génération, on l'a mis dans les
cartons. Donc là, on l'a plus et par
électrolyse, ça consomme beaucoup
d'énergie. Je rappelle juste que
l'hydrogène quand on le fabrique
aujourd'hui, 95 % c'est avec des
énergies fossiles au niveau mondial en
France. Donc c'est principalement gaz
mais aussi pétrole et tout gaz, on prend
du CH4 he du méthane et puis on enlève
le C avec qui avec un oxygène qui fera
du CO2 et reste le H quoi. Le C est plus
facile à casser que le que le haut. euh
pour l'électrolyse. Donc euh donc la
France euh 7 milliards d'euros je crois
orig 2030 donc 2 milliards à dépenser
d'ici de fin de 2021 c'est beaucoup
d'argent. Alors ce qui est intéressant
pour l'hydrogène c'est que c'était la
solution géniale pour la voiture parce
que ça permettait de prendre la même
voiture, le même suivi, le même 44 de
juste on change le réservoir d'essence,
on met un réservoir d'hydrogène et ça
roule. on fait aucun effort sur la
taille, sur nos comportements. Donc
c'était la solution technologique
parfaite. Sauf que il y a quelques
problèmes. On a parlé de la production
de l'hydrogène. Aujourd'hui, 95 % euh
c'est de l'hydrogène qu'on appelle gris
puisqu'il est carboné. Euh la solution
c'est bien sûr de le faire avec des
éoliennes et des panneaux solaires.
Alors de préférence les éoliennes quand
on a pas besoin de l'électricité, ça
s'appelle en anglais c'est le
curtainilement. Donc c'est le moment où
le vent souffle et que il est 3h du
matin et qu'il y a que les les boîtes de
nu qui tournent. Donc là, on pourrait
fabriquer de l'hydrogène avec un
électrolyseur,
sauf que ça, ça représente 5 % du temps.
Donc c'est pas des grosses quantités.
Euh et dans le transport, on a des
grosses quantités de pétrole. Euh
l'autre problème de l'hydrogène, c'est
que sur la voiture électrique, par
exemple, la plupart des gens qui nous
écoutent ont chez eux une prise de
courant. D'accord ? Donc ils pourraient
théoriquement, s'ils ont une place de
parking charger une voiture électrique.
Ils ont pas de prise à hydrogène.
Aujourd'hui, donc avec ma prise de
courant, je peux couvrir 80 % de ma
mobilité. tous mes trajets du quotidien.
Après, il y a un certain nombre de
conditions où j'ai une place de parking,
une prise, une deuxième voiture parce
que pour partir en vacances c'est
compliqué et que je roule au moins 40 km
par jour sinon je retrouve jamais mon
argent. Donc c'est beaucoup de
conditions et à la fin de l'histoire, il
reste entre 20 et 30 % des Français qui
peuvent qui rentrent dans ces casesl.
Mais l'hydrogène, il y a même pas ça.
Donc le réseau juste un ordre de
grandeur sur les prix, combien ça coûte
une pompe à essence ? Un pistolet, ça
coûte à peu près 10000 €.
Quand on met une bande de recharge
électrique rapide, on va dire environ
entre 50 100000 € peut-être pour les
plus rapides. Une pompe à hydrogène un
pistolet, c'est 1 million d'euros
pour l'instant.
Et c'est un million depuis 10 ans. Moi
je ça a pas bougé depuis 10 ans. C'est
reste un million. Il y a pas d'économie
d'échelle de toute façon il y a pas de
marché. Donc qu'est-ce qui se passe sur
l'autoroute en France ? Vous avez 400
stations. Chacune des 400 stations a 10
pistolets. Donc 400 x 10 ça fait 4000.
fois 1 million 4 milliards et ça ça
couvre que la longue distance donc 20 %
des trajets. On rajoute la courte
distance, on rajoute 4 milliards. Donc
c'est 10 milliards d'euros qu'il faut
mettre demain pour avoir un réseau
équivalent à ce qu'on a sur l'essence.
Bon aujourd'hui, on n'est même pas foutu
d'installer un réseau pour charger les
voitures électriques. Le réseau qui
existe en France qui s'appelle le réseau
Corridor qui a été payé notamment à
moitié par la Commission européenne et
arrêter. Il y a pas et ça coûte je vous
dis 50000 €. Donc pour aller chercher 10
milliards euh ça va être un tout petit
peu compliqué. Et il y a pas aujourd'hui
déjà sur la voiture électrique de modèle
économique pour la recharge rapide sur
les autoroutes. Ça n'existe pas. C'est
pour ça qu'il y a pas de de gens qui
investissent. À cela, sur l'hydrogène,
c'est vous aurez pas de réseau, vous
n'aurez pas l'infrastructure de
recharge. Donc alors la bonne nouvelle,
c'est que les lobbyistes même de
l'hydrogène aujourd'hui disent "OK,
l'hydrogène c'est pas pour la voiture."
Je sais pas si le gouvernement l'a
entendu, mais quand on parle aux
lobbyistes de l'hydrogène, ils disent
"C'est pas pour la voiture, par contre
ça va faire rouler les avions verts, les
bateaux verts, les camions verts, les
camionettes verts." Il va falloir aussi
prévoir un bon stock de peinture verte
si possible de fabriquer ça en France.
Mais donc on va mettre alors le plan de
cette minière à quoi il sert si j'ai
bien compris c'est surtout pour investir
dans la fabrication d'électrolyseur
parce que le gros problème c'est ça
coûte très cher un électrolyseur donc
faut faire baisser les coûts. Donc en
gros on nous explique que ce qu'on a pas
réussi à faire avec les panneaux
solaires qui sont partis en Chine avec
les éoliennes qui sont partis en Chine
avec les batteries qui sont en Chine et
la voiture électrique qui est en Chine
on va réussir à le faire avec les
électrolyseurs. Donc moi je j'attends
pour voir mais je reste sceptique.
Vous vous en tant qu'expert quand vous
écoutez notre gouvernement
brasser du vent, sculter de l'air chaud,
c'est que c'est quoi votre réaction
devant votre poste de télé ? C'est par
qui est conseillé ce gars-là pour
raconter autant de conneries ? Il a mis
ses lunettes roses ce soir. C'est
qu'est-ce qui vous passe par la tête
quand vous vous les entendez lâcher des
énormités pareilles ?
Déjà, moi j'ai pas la télé quoi. Ça
m'évite justement de de trop de trop
m'énerver.
Mais euh en fait oui, on voit bien qu'on
est dans une dans une course au aux
annonces quoi. Voilà, et avec les
annonces qui peut-être un peu se voilà,
c'est c'est Sarkozi qui avait inventé ça
en tout cas en France quoi. C'est une
annonce en chasse une autre et comme ça
avant qu'on ait eu le temps de réfléchir
et décortiquer la précédente, il y a
déjà un nouveau truc qui est arrivé. Euh
effectivement alors avec tout cette
magie toujours des des chiffres, les 100
milliards d'euros et les trucs, il faut
atteindre. Bon, c'est vrai que ça ça
donne presque le le vertige et moi ça me
donne presque envie de de pas m'y
intéresser beaucoup. Après sur
l'hydrogène, moi j'ai l'impression tu
disais très justement l'hydrogène pour
la voiture parce que tu as il y a une ou
deux choses que tu as pas mentionné en
plus, je me permets de de les rajouter,
c'est l'hydrogène c'est un gaz qui est
un peu embêtant parce que c'est un tout
petit gaz donc en fait ça fuit.
Euh
euh ouais mais même plus je pense que
c'est même plus petit effectivement.
Alors l'avantage de de l'hydrogène pour
l'histoire c'est que le
il il se si vous lâchez l'hydrogène dans
la dans la nature il va monter parce
qu'il est très léger mais il va se
recombiner avec la couche d'ozone et il
va refaire de l'eau. Il va retomber. Ce
qui fait qu'en fait la la grâce à la
couche d'ozone la Terre a conservé son
hydrogène et a donc conserver son eau.
L'hélium ça marche pas comme ça. Quand
vous relâcher votre hélium de votre
ballon de Mickey, l'hélium part dans
l'espace pour toujours. Donc l'hélium
est une ressource non renouvelable qui
en fait est récupérée aujourd'hui dans
un certain nombre de gaz de de de poches
de gaz naturel. En fait, c'est la
dégradation de l'uranium 238 qui qui a
accumulé cet hélium. Et donc il y a un
moment il y en aura plus. Donc comme on
en utilise dans les dans les IRM et tout
ça, on fera se poser la question. Mais
bon, pour l'hydrogène, on n pas de sujet
parce que on a cette couche de zone.
Donc donc il fuit, il y a pas de
réservoir étanche et en plus il a le
mauvais goût quand il se met avec un
dans des proportions stockiométriques
d'exploser. Voilà. Donc euh c'est très
embêtant euh et donc ça ça ça réclame
vraiment tout un tout un travail je
pense industriel de réflexion à ça qui
qui milite aussi au-delà de la question
du d'un d'un déploiement économiquement
sans doute très complexe au fait que ça
soit sur des usages plutôt de type on va
dire professionnel. Donc ça pourrait
être aussi peut-être je sais pas des
trains, des bus trucs comme ça. Enfin
voilà c'est en fait plutôt des
entreprises qui auraient des trucs
dédiés pour pouvoir recharger j'en sais
rien et pas effectivement monsieur tout
le monde sur l'autoroute avec son truc.
Bon, on verra mais effectivement c'est
plutôt ça. Mais moi j'ai l'impression
que l'hydrogène en fait à la fois enfin
me semble-t-il peut-être je me trompe
mais c'est un peu pour apporter une
réponse à l'aérien en fait à la question
de l'aérien c'est au moment où on a à la
fois le flixcam on commence à dire que
quand même oui enfin il nous raconte à
chaque fois que c'est x % des émissions
seulement sauf que quand je réintègre le
transport international sauf que quand
je réintègre les traînés les effets
climatiques et cetera, bah à la fin ça
se voit quand même un petit peu plus que
ce qu'on croirait. C'est pas juste
l'épaisseur du trait. plus arrive la
crise sanitaire et donc le la nécessité
de de sauter sur sur Colvie et d'aller
accompagner tout tout le secteur, bah il
faut
apporter une promesse quoi qui soit pas
juste on va soutenir un secteur qui est
horrible parce que ça nous envoie dans
dans le mur climatique et autres et que
c'est finalement presque le le le voilà
un secteur emblématique encore un peu
comme la 5G de de de ce monde à
l'hypermobilité à l'hyperpollution et
donc du coup bah on sort l'hydrogène
parce que ça permet de dire oui on
pourra mettre des milliards pour
soutenir la filière aéronautique qui est
quand même une filière des rares
filières d'excellence qui est pas qui
est pas partie à gauche ou à droite en
délocalisation
et donc pour justifier ça je pense qu'il
y a besoin de convoquer l'hydrogène et
l'avion vert à un horizon pas trop
lointain d'où le le 2035 et puis le les
annonces un peu qui s'enchaînent bon
rendez-vous en 2035 mais j'ai
effectivement ça va être un gros gros
gros challenge quo
Nicolas les les formulations
incantatoires de nos politique
sur la pollution, l'hydrogène, la
consommation énergétique, la
consommation de ressources. Vous vous
êtes quand quand vous êtes devant votre
poste de télé
et que vous vous avez les datas en main,
les vraies, la bonne sour et quand vous
les entendez parler, ça vous fait quoi ?
Je me dis que [raclement de gorge] on a
encore un tout petit peu à attendre
avant que le monde d'après disparaisse.
Ça va prendre du temps. C'est quoi le
monde ?
Avant que le monde d'avant disparaisse,
on a tout un système en place qui qui
avec un certain d'entre soi où tous les
gens qui décident ont intérêt à
préserver au maximum leur position. Donc
tant qu'ils y arrivent, il y a pas de
raison que ça change. Euh donc il faut
un choc, il faut une sorte de
d'effondrement entre guillemets, une
sorte de reset euh pour repartir sur
autre chose et probablement un reset du
modèle, probablement un reset de
certaines règles peut-être de commerce
international, je sais pas quoi. Mais
aujourd'hui,
on fait semblant, on fait des annonces
mais la trajectoire ne dévit pas d'OTA.
Quand vous regardez par exemple les
émissions de CO2 au niveau mondial,
c'est entre guillemets très drôle. C'est
ça le serait si c'est mais ça donne
envie de pleurer quand même. En fait,
depuis qu'on s'intéresse aux émissions
de CO2, donc c'est date de à peu près
fin des années 90 2000, on a jamais
autant augmenté les émissions de CO2.
On a jamais fait pire en fait. Et moi,
je me pose la question, est-ce que
finalement on a peut-être pas dû en
parler ? Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ? Bah
tout simplement, et là on est en France
champion du monde là-dessus. Euh bah, on
a délocalisé notamment une grande partie
de nos émissions en Chine. La Chine
arrive dans l'OMC en 2001 et donc là, la
majorité des pays industrialisés
délocalise beaucoup de la production qui
était parfois faite en France et avec du
décarboné du nucléaire. Dans d'autres
pays, mais c'était pas en tout cas 80 %
au charbon. Et puis ensuite, on a eu le
on a eu aussi les nouveaux États-membres
qui sont arrivés en 2004 dans l'Europe.
Hop là, ça part à nouveau au charbon en
Pologne é dans tous ces pays-là. Et
quand on regarde finalement l'empreinte
carbone de la France depuis 90, c'est
plus 20 %. Voilà. Alors si on regarde
que ce qu'on a fait chez nous, bah c'est
- 20 % alors on serait au joui hein.
C'est les émissions sur le sol français.
Donc mais c'est - 20 % qui qui dit aussi
un certain nombre de centaines de
milliers d'emplois qui partent qui
partent aussi avec les émissions. Donc
c'est une blague et en 2019 on n jamais
autant émis de CO2 de l'histoire de ou
peut-être 2018, je sais pas de
l'histoire de l'humanité. Donc c'est
juste une blague, c'est une mascarade.
Voilà. Alors après sur les chiffres, moi
je m' c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup
d'effets d'annonce et il y a un secteur
où ils sont spécialistes, c'est les
voitures électriques. Et ça se compte
souvent soit c'est des centaines de
milliers ou c'est par 100000 ou 500000.
Donc le premier, je vais regarder les
chiffres, c'est ce que je fais quand je
vois ça. Je vais regarder les chiffres.
Le premier c'est Jean-Louis Borlot en
2008 avec le Grenel d'environnement. Il
annonce, je crois, pour euh 2015 400000
bandes de recharge électrique. 400000
c'était avant ou après le déjeuner ?
Ça je sais pas mais je crois qu'il
commence,
il me semble qu'il commence au
petit-déjeuner de 400000 400000 en 2015.
Euh bon, bien sûr, ça glisse. Euh après,
il me semble que Sen Royal euh en
qu'est-ce qu'elle nous annonce ? Je
crois qu'en 2016, elle nous redit un
100000 ou je crois qu'elle est montée à
1 million, elle 1 million en 2020. Euh
et puis après, on a repris un autre
objectif 100000 en 2022. Là, on est à
100000 en 2021. 100000 en 2021 euh et
400000 en 2015. En je les trucs sont
jamais atteints. Carlos Gon avait été
aussi très bon. Euh il se lance en 2011
avec sa sa Nissan Leaf, je vais en
vendre 500000 en 2015. Combien est-ce
qu'il en vend en 2015 ? 50000. Donc il y
a beaucoup d'effets d'annonce et c'est
d'ailleurs comme ça que Tesla existe et
que Tesla est aujourd'hui devenu le
premier constructeur, c'est parce que
c'est la capacité d'Elon Musk à dire des
gros chiffres et à ce que les invests le
croient. Et donc il a pu lever beaucoup
d'argent. Aujourd'hui, il est rentable.
A priori je pense qu'ils sont sortis euh
ils sont sortis de d'affaires. Mais mais
on est sur des histoires de gros
chiffres. L'impact sur le climat euh bah
c'est c'est quasiment nul. Juste, je
veux revenir sur un truc dont a parlé
Philippe Wix. Moi, je vais commencer à
les écouter les hommes politiques quand
ils vont dire deux mots : Effet rebond.
Le jour où vous en avez un qui dit effet
rebond, là il faut commencer à
s'intéresser à ce qu'il dit. Je vous
prends deux exemples. La rénovation
thermique, un rapport qui est sorti sur
l'Allemagne récemment
depuis 10 ans. 300, je crois que c'est
300 milliards d'euros qu'ils ont mis la
consommation énergétique des euh des des
appartements n'a pas baissé. D'accord.
300 milliards d'euros pour la rénovation
thermique et en fait avec la baisse
notamment des énergies fossiles et du
gaz, ben les gens se sont chauffés plus.
Point final. Donc quand vous mettez vous
isolez mais que à côté vous augmentez
pas l'effet prix, bah les gens soit ils
chauffent plus ou soit ils dépensent
ailleurs, ils partent en vacances et
cetera. Donc impact zéro. Par contre pas
zéro pour le climat sur le confort, ils
sont plus à 19 ou 21, ils sont à 22 donc
c'est plus confortable et sur le climat
zéro. L'autre exemple c'est la voiture.
On regarde ça prè moi avec France
stratégie. Vous prenez les voitures
neuves depuis 20 ans,
la consommation par
l'efficacité des moteurs s'est amélioré
mais tous les gains qu'on a pu faire ont
été annulés intégralement par
l'augmentation de la taille des voitures
et de la puissance.
Alors on va parler de ça. Vous avez
proposé avec votre petit vos petits bras
une taxe sur le poids des voitures qui a
été d'ailleurs évacué si mes souvenirs
sont bons. Alors déjà pourquoi cette
taxe ? et de pourquoi ça a été évacué ?
Alors bon, ça c'est un sujet que qui me
tient à cœur depuis depuis assez
longtemps. J'étais d'ailleurs allé en en
2012 avec mon bâton de pèlerin euh pour
rencontrer euh le cabinet de d'Arnaub
Brondbourg euh pour euh 2013 d'ailleurs
pour parler de de ce sujet euh qui est
la qui me préoccupait qui est la taille
de la voiture.
Bon, bien évidemment, à l'époque,
c'était pas son agenda et donc ça
n'avait pas pas abouti. Et donc, je
publié quelque chose avec France
Stratégie en 2019 en juin. En partant du
constat, et ça peu de gens le savent,
c'est que effectivement les émissions de
CO2 des voitures neuves n'ont pas baissé
depuis 20 ans. En 2019, les émissions de
CO2 des voitures neuves étaient
plus élevées que l'objectif qu'avait
fixé la Commission européenne pour 2000.
5 14 ans de retard 14 ans et on on et et
donc on a vu qu'en fait elles ont baissé
en laboratoire
donc les constructeurs ont optimisé les
cycles, ce qui a agrandi l'écart entre
le laboratoire et la réalité mais qu'en
fait ça n'a pas baissé dans la réalité.
Le seul moment où ça a baissé dans la
réalité c'était entre 2008 et 2010.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ? Crise
financière. Donc on vend moins de
grosses voitures notamment aux gens les
plus aisés et deux à l'époque on a mis
en place notamment en France un bonus
malus sur les émissions de CO2 qui
favorisaient les petites voitures. Donc
on a vendu plus de petites voitures,
moins de grosses voitures. C'est le seul
moment où les émissions de CO2 des
voitures neuves ont baissé. Donc on
s'est dit OK, la solution est pas très
compliquée, faut vendre moins de grosses
voitures, plus de petites voitures. Donc
ce qu'on a proposé c'est pas de mettre
une taxe en plus, c'est d'avoir un
système un peu redistributif pour
récompenser les comportements vertueux.
En gros, on prend le poids moyen des
voitures vendues. Alors nous, on s'est
placé au niveau européen, c'est à peu
près 1 tonne 350.
Ceux qui veulent sacher une voiture un
peu plus grosse, pas de problème. Par
contre, ça va leur coûter un peu plus
cher pour que ceux qui sont prêts à
faire un effort et à s'acheter une
voiture un peu plus petite
bah puisse récupérer cet argent donc
redistributif hein à 100 % avec des
exemptions qu'on garde notamment pour
les personnes familles nombreuses. On n
pas imposé à tout le monde avec trois
enfants de rouler en Twingo. C'était pas
encore le principe. des exemples aussi
sur les voitures électriques
puisqueaujourd'hui effectivement une
voiture électrique elle embarque une
partie de son plein de carburant pendant
dans la batterie donc elle pèse plus
lourd donc ce serait la la pénalisée et
donc ça on et donc ça c'est quand on l'a
publié en fait en en juin 2019 ça a été
plutôt bien reçu. Les gens ont bien
compris ce qu'on voulait faire.
C'est qui les gens ?
Euh alors ça a été beaucoup repris dans
les médias. Moi, j'ai eu des discussions
avec certains députés notamment comme
Mathieu Felin et son équipe qui après
eux ont en fait dans le projet de loi
des finances 2021
ont voulu non 2020 pardon ont voulu
mettre des amendements et il faut savoir
qu'en fait mon système c'était de mettre
un bonus malus. Donc moi j'ai discuté
avec eux et puis le jour où sort
l'amendement je vois qu'il y a que le
malus et je dis mais non mais là il y a
un problème. L'idée de cette chose là
c'est que ce soit redistributif
et d'encourager la vente de voiture
légère.
Et en fait, un député n'a pas le droit,
c'est la Constitution, je crois,
l'article 40, n'a pas le droit de
rajouter des charges au budget de
l'État. Donc ils peuvent, il y a que le
gouvernement qui peut le faire par
décret et donc le truc a été retoqué.
Alors, il se trouve aussi que nous
normalement nos notes elles circulent
dans les ministères et là que le
notamment la DGC l'avait pas reçu, donc
ils ont pas compris ce qu'on avait fait.
Euh et donc ça a été retoqué euh par la
commission des finances et puis après
par Ellisabeth Born euh et notamment le
rapporteur à l'époque du PLF qui était
Joël [raclement de gorge] Girot qui est
le député euh des Hall des autres Alpes
ou un truc comme ça et qui disait qu'
forcément chez lui tout le monde roulait
en 44 donc c'était stupide. Donc ça
s'est arrêté là et puis c'est revenu
dans le débat avec la convention
citoyenne.
Donc qui l'a qui se l' réapproprié, qui
l'a proposé en juin qui ne faisait pas
partie des jokers des trois jokers
d'Emmanuel Macron. Sauf que la
convention citoyenne a laissé les
voitures électriques dedans. Donc quand
c'est arrivé dans le débat en en
septembre, les constructeurs automobiles
ont fait mais voilà nous on nous demande
de faire des voitures électriques et
vous nous pénalisez. Et donc et donc le
truc directement est parti à la poubelle
et là il y a une nouvelle version qui
arrive. Alors je dois juste rappeler un
petit truc qui était très drôle. Enfin,
pas vraiment très drôle, mais il
proposaient eux une taxe au-dessus, un
malus au-dessus de 1 tonne 4 et un bonus
sous 1 tonne 2. Et vous avez Luc Châtel
qui est arrivé un matin sur BFM chez
Bourdin, je sais pas où et qui a dit
c'est UBS qu'une taxe comme ça, ça va
concerner 70 % de la production de
voiture en France.
et argument d'autorité repris par tous
les médias. Aucun média n'a fa checké et
ni moi.
Et puis finalement, je je fais un
interview avec l'usine nouvelle et puis
je lis dans l'interview euh qu'en fait
c'est pas 70 %, c'est 17
et en fait et donc je creuse le sujet en
fait c'est pas 17, c'est 12 %. Donc il
arrivé avec son argument d'autorité 70 %
des voitures françaises touchéaient. En
fait non, le chiffre c'était 12. Et donc
il a envoyé ça, il a envoyé ça à la
poubelle. Il y a une dernière version
qui est sortie qui est intéressante où
là on n plus à 1 ton4, on a 1 tonne 7.
Euh parce que je trouve que ce qui est
important, c'est le signal. Euh la
France met en place une fiscalité sur le
poids pour inciter les voitures plus
légères. Le signal est important pour
les autres pays. Et là à 1 ton7, j'ai
fait le calcul, enfin on quelqu'un l'a
fait pour moi. Euh ça concernait 0,28 %
de la production en France et ça a été
retoqué. par la commission des finances.
Donc c'est pas donc c'est pas gagné.
J'ouvre une parenthèse, il y a un nos
auditeurs qui nous dit "On on n'est pas
foutu d'installer des bornes
électriques. De point c'est faux.
Les bornes de recherge installées par
BUIG en Oxitan coûtent environ 20 kg euh
par borne. Facture consulté entre
parenthèses car la personne en charge
était en arrêt maladie quand le prix est
passé de 10 à 20 kg par borne de
recharge. Le problème du déploiement
d'un nouveau mode énergétique est
d'abord un problème de non corruption du
BTP.
Alors sur les sur les bandes de
recharge, ce qui ce qui est vrai, c'est
que en fait dans les au début des années
2010, comme c'était le début des
voitures électriques disponibles, les
collectivités notamment ont installé des
bornes de recharge en ville parce que
les voitures à l'époque avaient des
autonomies de 120 130 150 km et donc il
fallait rassurer les gens pour qu'
tombent pas en panne et donc qu'il
puissent se charger. Sauf que ce qui
s'est passé depuis 10 ans, c'est que le
prix des batteries a été divisé par 10
au kilwh. Ce qui a fait d'ailleurs un
effet rebond sur les batteries puisque
pour un prix équivalent de batterie, on
a augmenté l'autonomie et donc toutes
ces bornes de recharge qui ont été
installées dans l'espace public par les
collectivités ne sont plus utilisées
parce que les gens chargent chez eux,
ils ont plus besoin de faire ces
recharges d'apoint. Aujourd'hui sur la
recharge électrique, vous avez deux
points noirs.
Le premier point noir, je vous en ai
parlé, c'est la longue distance, c'est
mettre des bandes de recharge rapides
qui vont être très peu utilisé mais qui
doivent être suffisamment nombreuses
pour couvrir la demande de pointe lors
du weekend de l'Ascension, de la
Pente-côte ou les vacances de Noël.
Et moi, je suis sceptique.
J'ai une petite question pour Philippe,
une question internet.
Que pensent-il des supraconducteurs avec
l'hydrogène ? N'est-ce pas une piste
pour l'avenir ?
Question de qui
les
supraconducteurs. Les supraconducteurs
pour l'hydrogène. Alors autant j'aurais
pu bien convoquer les hydrures de les
hydrures pour stocker le gaz qui donc
effectivement sont sera une solution
pour voilà solide pour pour stocker
autant les supraconducteurs
histoire de température non j'en sais
rien. Je je je passe mon tour. Mais bon
qui dit supraconducteur dit de toute
manière
euh voilà capacité à produire et à
maintenir du froid. Donc ça embarque en
général déjà une une complexité
technologique et économique à mon avis
assez assez dure.
Alors ça c'est une question une question
que je vais reformuler. Euh
quelle serait la mesure la plus efficace
à adopter de suite au niveau individuel
et collectif ? Donc ça c'est une
question internet de Mathieu.
Alors Nicolas Millon, il dit toujours
"Mettez un pull, chauffez-vous à 18°gr
et prenez un vélo".
Ah le pull, je l'ai piqué Philippe. Pas
Ah ah ah ah. Donc le donc Philippe le
pull.
Euh alors déjà, je je je contesterai un
tout petit peu la la question en disant
attention, il y a il y a effectivement
ce niveau individuel, très bien, super,
mais après on est tous enchassés dans un
système et donc
il faut aussi venir transformer système
sinon en fait on gagne pas grandchose.
Je crois qu'il y avait une étude de
Carbone 4 qui avait montré que si vous
vous transformez en ayat laav totalement
végétarien,
déjà utiliser le mot Ayat. Bah parce que
amiche machin tant qu' tant qu'on y est
non mais il ne faut pas utiliser les
armes de l'ennemi pour se qualifier.
D'accord. Alors OK, autant pour moi.
Donc si vous vous transformez en
vraiment en végétarien patenté à vélo et
et étant extrêmement sobre consommation
en achetant FRIP et je sais pas quoi,
mais en fait vous arrivez à baisser
votre bilan carbone mais pas du facteur
4, loin de là. Et pourquoi ? Parce qu'on
est embarqué dans un système qui lui bah
il y a aussi des infrastructures, il y a
plein d'autres choses autour. le système
industriel, le système de transport de
de de bien de marchandises, même si
c'est des carottes, faut les
transporter. Donc tout ça, ça fait qu'on
gagne pas tant que ça. Donc le niveau
individuel, il est il est hyper
important, mais il faudra savoir monter
à l'étage du dessus ou aux étages du
dessus. Il y a un étage qui est un étage
pour moi territorial, donc ça va de
l'association du coin, du rifé en
passant par l'interpellation bah des
métropoles, des régions et cetera. Il y
a des plein de choses à faire à ce
niveau. Et puis il y a l'interpellation
de l'étage du dessus qui est la question
la question fiscale, la question enfin
les choses qui concerne le niveau
étatique. Donc la fiscalité, ouais, on
taxe, on taxe pas, la norme, la
réglementation, on interdit, on autorise
euh la question du soutien à
l'innovation justement, est-ce qu'on où
est-ce qu'on met les milliards et cetera
? Alors, si je reviens sur le d'abord
sur la partie
personnelle, bon chacun peut faire ses
choix, mais on va dire allez je vais
dire acheter un livre de recette
végétarienne. Voilà, donc parce que
c'est une manière réduire la quantité de
viande, c'est quand même une manière
assez efficace à cause de l'effet
méthane en particulier et puis à cause
d'effets déporté de type déforestation,
soja au Brésil et cetera. Donc ça ça
embarque quand même un bilan carbone
assez sympathique. Ensuite euh
effectivement peut-être se poser la
question de la manière dont vous abordez
le confort thermique par rapport à bien
éteindre les lumières, on va dire parce
que bon effectivement éteindre lumière
c'est bien, ça fait pas de mal, c'est
gratuit mais ça va pas forcément gagner
grand-chose par rapport à réussir à
réduire de à réguler son chauffage. Déjà
des fois il l'est pas euh en Russie il
régule comme le gaz est pas cher, ils en
ont beaucoup. Il régule avec la taille
de la de l'ouverture de la fenêtre
grosso modo. Donc il faut essayer
d'éviter de faire ça. Donc réguler son
chauffage et essayer de de gagner entre
sur la température jour nuit et puis
évidemment éviter aussi la climatisation
de l'autre côté pour le confort
thermique d'été qui embarque pas mal de
choses et pour le coup en plus des gaz à
effet de serre dans le dans le système.
Oui.
Donc voilà ce genre de choses là sur la
mobilité bah c'est essayer de
privilégier le vélo quand on peut
évidemment c'est facile à dire. Sinon,
des petites voitures. Euh et puis euh et
puis après euh bah on va tomber, c'est
quoi le à part le on va dire le
logement, le déplacement
et la nourriture, vous on doit embarquer
déjà 80 ou 85 % je pense de du gaz
important dans ce que ce que ce que tu
achètes et tout. Alors après voilà, il
reste les objets de la consommation et
en particulier des choses par exemple
électroniques. Dans un objet
électronique, vous avez 85 % de des
dégâts qui ont été fait qui sont fait à
la fabrication, à l'achat pour un pour
un smartphone ou un ordinateur. Donc
c'est effectivement essayer de les
changer le moins souvent possible. Donc
en en prenant soin, on en les
entretenant. Un ordinateur ça
s'entretient de la même manière qu'on
entretient une voiture ou un vélo. Ça se
ça se dépoussière, ça se ça se le disque
dur et cetera. Il y a des choses à
faire.
Voilà.
CSD quoi.
C'est un Ouais.
Donc euh voilà, c'est un peu tout ça. Et
puis après, je pense que voilà, il y a
il y a il y a ensuite il y a l'effet
d'entraînement. Alors l'effet
d'entraînement qu'on peut avoir à
nouveau au niveau un peu associatif ou
territorial, l'effet d'entraînement
qu'on peut avoir là où on bosse, c'est
pas forcément facile mais moi je moi
j'ai quand même l'impression que c'est
pour se donner un peu de beau mour quand
même que voilà, il y a peut-être une
sorte de pseudo 5e colonne qui émerge si
on peut dire. Enfin, en tout cas des
gens qui s'intéressent à ça et qui se
prennent les choses par le bon bout un
peu partout.
Bah dans les dans les institutions, dans
les voilà dans dans les institutions,
dans les entreprises, enfin la parole se
libère un peu quand même. On voit des
choses où enfin des des exercices de
prospective où voilà, on n'est pas juste
dans le business as usual et dans le
tableau Excel avec 2 % de croissance par
an et tout va bien jusque
jusque enfin pour des siècles et des
siècles. Donc voilà, on va essayer de
jouer là-dessus parce que il me semble
que cette voilà c'est le premier risque
en fait quand on a pris un peu
conscience de du du mur si je puis dire.
Alors le le mur, il peut être juste un
peu moral quoi. C'est-à-dire que dans
les dans les prévisions du GC, par
exemple, on est toujours sur la question
de la mer, elle va monter de combien ?
Est-ce que ça va 70 cm ou 1,20 en l'an
2100 ? Et l'aventure s'arrête pas en
l'an 2100, hein. Si on se projette un
peu plus loin, le coût est parti. Et
donc de toute manière la mer va monter
et puis va monter un petit peu plus que
1,20 quoi. Donc
plaisir, il y a toutes nos centrales
nucléaires proche de la mer. Bah
tout à fait voilà bien sûr. Alors elle
sera un tout petit peu plus chaude donc
pour refroidir mais donc voilà donc du
coup il y a quand même un voilà il y a
un espèce de de coup gigantesque qui est
parti. Alors la bonne nouvelle c'est
qu'on le verra pas normalement parce que
on sera pas tous des transhumanistes qui
allont vivre 1000 ans. On va tous mourir
comme il faut comme les autres. Donc,
mais voilà pour ce que ça embarque d'un
point de vue poids moral de pour
l'humanité, c'est assez assez
désagréable quand même. Donc j'ai
l'impression que voilà ce ce devant
cette solitude potentielle bah de d'être
de plus en plus à penser des choses et à
les dire c'est c'est je sais pas si j'en
avais parlé l'autre fois parce que comme
ça fait long plusieurs fois que je passe
mais voilà ouais comme c'est la 5è fois
je finis par sans doute adoter et je
m'en excuse par avance mais c'est
c'estin qui disait en 74 en URSS donc
bon il faut quand même voilà il disait
le le système s'écroulera le jour où à
chaque fois qu'on entendra une connerie
dans une salle on se lèvera et on
partira alors évidemment le premier qui
se lève et qui part après avoir entendu
la connerie, celui-là, ça se passait pas
bien en 74, hein. Donc voilà. Mais du
coup, le fait est que effectivement 10
ans plus tard, Glass Nost et tout, bon,
on commence un petit peu à libérer la
parole et et le château de carte
s'écroule assez vite finalement. Donc
là, moi il me semble qu'on vit dans un
monde encore qui est encore très euh qui
a quelques caractéristiques
staliniennes, quelques hein, bien sûr,
la métaphore s'arrête assez vite
ensuite, mais et notamment la capacité à
dire voilà les gens qui sont en position
de pouvoir, qui sont en position de
pouvoir politique ou de pouvoir des
entreprises ou le pouvoir institutionnel
au sens large, finalement voilà, on est
tous un petit peu peureux avec eux et
puis on a du mal à les interpeller et
puis ils ont l'air très sérieux, ils
nous alignent les milliards et on n'ose
pas contester ou enfin c'est difficile
de contester ou l'interpeller.
Alors qu'en fait, on passe notre temps.
Enfin, c'est c'est incroyable le ce
niveau de de green washing possible dans
le je pense notamment dans les
entreprises et c'est ces papiers en ces
ces rapports en papiers glacés qui
s'alignent les uns derrière les autres
pour expliquer qu'ils vont sauver la
planète. Enfin et c'est c'est et c'est
toutes ces ces coloques et cetera.
Enfin, c'est quand même assez
hallucinant par rapport à la réalité des
choses quoi. Donc euh il me semble que
voilà, rien que soulever la couverture
et dire "Mais quand même tout ça est un
petit peu faux." Enfin, je sera compter
que je sais pas sur des des grands
énergéticiens par exemple que je ne
citerai pas mais pas pasf mais
expliquant que voilà ça va être la la
révolution par le numérique et il est
renouvelable et que ça continue à
aligner de la centrale à charbon et et
de et de et du gros barrage
hydroélectrique sur forêt tropical s'il
vous plaît parce que c'est quand même
mieux pour le méthane. Voilà c'est c'est
quand même un peu les mettre devant la
responsabilité de temps en temps. Ça
ferait du bien quoi.
Ouais, je pense que je repensais à ce
qu'on avait dit sur Emmanuel Macron. Je
pense qu'on a été un peu un peu sévère
pour essayer de voir le verre à moitié
plein parce que ce qu'on va quand même
peut-être retenir d'Emmanuel Macron sur
le climat, c'est que c'est pas très loin
d'avoir un titre de champion du monde
des comités Thodules. Et il avait
commencé avec son élection avec le Maker
Planet Greeten pour se distinguer face à
Donald Trump qui potentiellement a plus
baissé ses émissions que lui puisque en
passant de du charbon au gaz
électricité, ça permet de réduire assez
fortement ses émissions de CO2. ce qu'il
avait fait d'ailleurs son prédécesseur.
Euh mais il a créé One Planet Summit.
Euh ensuite ensuite il a créé euh le au
conseil pour le climat dont je vais
parler un peu plus tard. Puis il a créé
pose la question
puis il a créé puis il a créé la
conférence citoyenne. Il a créé aussi le
grand débat et le conseil de défense
écologique. Ce que
fait des numéros verts aussi.
Ouais. Et ce que j'ai lu récemment,
c'est que dans les médias, c'est qu'il
se cherchait sur l'environnement ou sur
le climat. Donc a priori, il a peut-être
pas eu la réponse à la question. Je vais
quand même parler du au conseil pour le
climat parce qu'ils ont publié un
rapport intéressant et ça après le le
mot
effet rebond, il y a un autre mot qui
est important et si vous l'entendez d'un
politique, vous vous ouvrez les oreilles
et les yeux aussi, c'est émission
importé.
Donc les émissions à porté de la France
et et moi je pense que le premier
politique vous dira qu'en fait pour
faire baisser les émissions de CO2
mondial, il faut augmenter les nôtres
parce que c'est ça qu'il faut faire. Ça
a eu beaucoup de succès
avec le Covid-19. On a parlé beaucoup de
souveraineté, de relocalisation
et c'est ça le sujet. La France c'était
le pays avec l'électricité la plus
décarbonée au monde. Ça vient avec un
certain nombre de désavantages qu'il
faut gérer des agréments. Mais c'est
factuel. La France devrait être l'usine
du monde. Ça devrait pas être la Chine
ça à 80 % au charbon. Ça devrait pas
être l'Inde, ça devrait pas être la
Pologne, ça devrait être la France. Et
donc ça veut dire en nous en
relocalisant la production, on va faire
augmenter nos émissions mais au final on
va faire baisser notre empreinte et
baisser donc nos émissions au global.
Donc le vrai projet politique, c'est pas
tous ceux qui vous disent on va mettre
zéro émission de CO2, c'est ceux qui
vous disent bah on va relocaliser la
production et donc augmenter nos
émissions de CO2 sur cette partie-là. Ce
qui est d'ailleurs l'industrie, c'est
c'est le secteur qui a le plus baissé
ses émissions de CO2 depuis 90, je crois
que c'est moins 40 % avec un peu de
productivité et un peu de
délocalisation. Sauf que sauf que c'est
pas possible quand Bruno Lemire vous dit
"Je vais relocaliser les les voitures,
la petite voiture", le problème c'est
que ça marche pas. La la petite voiture
électrique, demain on va l'acheter, elle
sera fabriquée en Chine parce que à mon
avis c'est pas compatible euh tout
simplement avec les traités
internationaux, soit le traité de
Lisbonne, les règles de l'OMC. Alors,
l'OMC, on pourrait peut-être faire
quelque chose puisqu'on a le droit de
faire des entorses au libre échamp. Euh,
mais comment vous voulez faire quand
vous vivez dans un pays d'Europe avec
les coûts euh les coûts euh les plus
élevés en terme de salaire et de droit
euh enfin de coûts sociaux, le droit
environnemental le plusation sociale,
sociale,
vous pouvez, on peut pas être concurrent
avec l'Ukraine, avec la Roumanie, avec
la Pologne ou alors on est payé à leur
salaire et on divise tout par quatre. Et
ça c'est ce qui se passe. On est dans un
monde de moinddisance sociale,
environnementale, fiscale aussi. Tant
qu'on a ces règles là de moins 10 ans,
il ne se passera rien.
Question pour vous deux, vous choisissez
qui va répondre. Quit de l'Union
européenne et de la loi climat
européenne. Encore plus de
délocalisation point d'interrogation.
Savez qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ? Ben
le la règle des émissions importées, ça
marche en France, ça marche aussi avec
l'Union européenne, c'est un peu moins
UEuropéenne. Je crois que c'est c'est
plutôt + 10 - 10. Donc on fait - 10 sur
les émissions, + 10 sur l'empreinte
carbone, [grognement] mais on reste dans
le même problème. Alors, il y a une
solution qui est le la mesure phare euh
de cette loi climat au niveau européen,
c'est la fameuse compensation aux
frontières. C'est cette fameuse, c'est
le serpent de la taxe carbone, je crois
dont Jacques Chirac a été le premier à
parler puis SarkoZi puis Hollande dans
son programme. Sarkozy l'avait il me
semble Hollande ça s'appelait un truc un
peu différemment indifférent. Donc c'est
cette fameuse compensation en gros
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? on taxe des
secteurs en Europe et pour pas les
pénaliser et bien on taxe les émissions,
les autres secteurs équivalents. Bon, ce
trucl c'est très compliqué à mettre en
marche. Ça veut peut-être être mis en
marche mais la bonne solution c'est sur
l'environnement en fait la bonne
solution c'est rarement la taxe. La
bonne solution c'est la norme.
Tu respectes quelque chose. Alors nous
par exemple, je vous donne un sur
baisser les émissions de CO2 des
voitures, on a dit bah écoute cette
voiture électrique,
ce serait peut-être mieux de la
fabriquer avec une électricité
décarbonée et pas au charbon hein.
Aujourd'hui, si vous voulez être citoyen
et sauver la planète et sauver vos
enfants, vous allez vous acheter une
Renault Zoé qui est la voiture la plus
vendue en France, électrique, qui est
assemblée pour l'instant à flin, dont la
batterie est aussi assemblée à fin, mais
dont les cellules de batterie sont
fabriquées
dans le pays avec l'électricité la plus
charbonnée au monde. Je cite la Pologne.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe en vrai ?
Giga factory, LG
Poli
et donc qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Ça veut
dire que vous quand je l'état vous donne
6 ou 7000 € pour acheter cette voiture,
en fait 7000 € ils vont où ? Bah ils
partent en Pologne pour subventionner
l'industrie de production de batterie au
charbon. Faites le calcul, il va se
vendre cette année plus de 20000 euh
voire 30000 300 c'est quoi les chiffres
? Non, j'ai plus le chiffre exactement.
fois je me calcule par 3 et je crois que
c'est 30000 reno en France fois 6000 €
vous êtes vous allez être à 200 millions
d'euros de subvention en 2020 de la
France vers la Pologne. Alors on sait
faire parce qu'on l'a fait sur le
solaire avec la Chine, on l'a fait sur
l'éolien on sait faire mais à titre de
comparaison on a un grand projet dont
Bruno Lumire est très fier l'irbus de la
batterie la France va investir 700
millions d'euros 700 millions d'euros
sur 5 ans. Donc 700 divis par 5 140.
Donc aujourd'hui, on donne 200 millions
d'euros à la Pologne pour fabriquer des
batteries au charbon et nous on investit
en France 150. Il y a un problème
d'ordre de grandeur. Je trouve difficile
sur juste un tac au tax, c'est que sur
cette histoire de compensation aux
frontières qu'on appellerait pas
forcément taxe carbone aux frontières,
mais ça a quand même ça a bougé parce
que il y a il y a 5 à 10 ans parler de
taxe aux frontières qu'elle soit carbone
ou autre chose, c'était être
nationaliste et vouloir la guerre en
gros enf dans la logique un peu de de
réduction systématique des des droits de
la communication a bougé. Ouais. Et et
enfin, moi je trouve que même voilà, il
y a il y a rien que se dire
qu'aujourd'hui tu as des euh
technocrates au niveau européen qui se
disent "Ah bah tiens, oui, c'est
peut-être une bonne idée quand même
parce que finalement on voit mal comment
on va réussir à à à bouger ça localement
sans sans mettre justement des
mécanismes de taxe ou de ou de permis
euh euh et d'émission échangeable ou
autre et sans avoir sans se faire casser
les reins de l'autre côté s'il y a pas
un mécanisme de compensation frontière."
Donc je trouve que ça a quand même un
peu bougé. Et ensuite ce que tu dis avec
la Pologne c'est enfin moi sur le le
problème sur la européenne que je vois
c'est c'est que c'est très difficile de
se mettre d'accord à 28 ou 27 ou je sais
plus ou 2 26 je sais je suis plus trop
les entrées sorties mais le
parce que on n pas tout à fait le le le
la même histoire le même destin, la même
les mêmes problématiques locales et les
mêmes tensions politiques au sein de
chacun des pays. que du coup ce déjà
qu'un débat dans un pays avec une seule
langue comme le nôtre, on voit le niveau
est pas très très élevé. réussir à avoir
ce débat-là en fait qui serait euh
transnational quelque part et
permettrait d'embarquer euh toute la
enfin toute une partie de la citoyenneté
européenne qui aura envie d'y aller y
compris des Polonais, y compris des
voilà parce que ces tensions-là, elles
existent dans tous les pays hein. Donc
je veux dire c'est pas euh tous les
Polonais sont pas des des méchants, on
est d'accord. Et euh et voilà et
réciproquement, moi j'assume pas la
politique de la France quand quand je
vais en Pologne. Enfin, j'y vais pas
beaucoup en ce moment.
Donc il y a ce trucl c'est voilà c'est
on sait qu'il y a un facteur de
complexité qui qui croit de manière sans
doute non linéaire avec le le nombre
qu'on est quoi. Si on se met un 5 dans
une pièce et on se dit où est-ce qu'on
part en vacances ? On peut discuter un
peu en fin par semaine d'accord on se
met 28 dans une pièce. On
reste à la maison
ça va être plus dur.
On a on a regardé ça justement parce
qu'au-delà de faire des propositions
est-ce que c'est est-ce que on peut le
mettre en place au niveau européen ? Il
y a la fiscalité sur lequel il me semble
on a besoin d'une majorité absolue sur
ce sujet-là, voir l'unanimité en fait
hein. Donc il faut être 26. Il y en a un
qui dit non pas de quelque chose fiscal
au niveau européen harmonisé niveau
européen. Voilà local par contre au
niveau local tu fais ce que tu veux.
niveau local, fais ce que tu veux. Le
truc que tu peux faire au niveau
européen, c'est les normes. Et les
normes c'est plus l'unanimité, c'est la
majorité qualifiée. En gros, si tu as la
France et l'Allemagne, à priori, ça
passe. Et donc nous, ce qu'on a proposé
c'est une norme sur le contenu carbone
de l'électricité utilisée
pour fabriquer les voitures vertes et
leur batteries. Donc en gros soit ta
voiture tu la fabriques et que tu me
montres que l'électricité que tu
utilises c'est moins de 200 g du kWh par
exemple et dans ce cas-là tu peux la
vendre. Soit c'est pas le cas et tu peux
pas la vendre. Ça c'est la version hard
en version soft. Soit ta voiture
électrique que tu vends en France elle
est fabriquée avec une électricité
décarbonée, moins de 200 g de kWh et
dans ce cas-là je te donne 6000 € mais
si c'est pas le cas tu as pas 6000 €.
Donc il y a il y a des versions plus ou
moins softes et ça ça peut être mis en
place
comme sur le poids. Tu peux taxer à 1
tonne 5 ou tu peux interdire à 1 tonne
5. Tu peux faire les deux parce que par
exemple en ville ça peut faire du sens
de on se dit que les voitures qui font
plus de tonnes en ville c'est pas
forcément pertinent.
Alors moi j'ai une question à vous poser
parce que là je viens de lire une
question un peu climatoceptique.
Qu'est-ce que vous répondez aux gens qui
sont climatosceptiques ? Je vous lis la
question. L'urgence climatique est un
leur trois points de suspension. Ces
tergiversations sur le dioxyde de
carbone sont agaçantes.
L'invité François Gervet, ce sera
autrement plus intéressant.
La réponse est très facile, c'est que le
climat c'est un des problèmes, mais il y
en a deux autres.
L'autre, un premier, c'est la pollution
atmosphérique et notamment en ville,
dans les zones concentrées, les
émissions de dioxyde d'azote. Les gens
ne le savent peut-être pas, mais nous
sommes hors la loi depuis maintenant
plus de 10 ans puisque la loi date de
2010. on on dépasse les niveaux
autorisés de depuis 10 ans, il ne se
passe rien sur les le dioxyde d'azote et
après il y a un problème de rare
effraction de pétrole. On va avoir en
reparler juste après.
Mais donc on a ces trois problèmes. Il
se trouve que la bonne nouvelle parce
qu'il en faut c'est qu'ils ont la même
solution.
Donc c'est réduire la consommation de
pétrole dans les voitures en ville et
donc ils ont un certain nombre de points
communs. Réduire la taille des voitures
et cetera et cetera. Donc entre
guillemets, on il y a des gens
effectivement qui sont euh sceptiques
sur ce sujet-là, mais le problème qui va
nous arriver euh il faut qu'il se pose
cette personne se pose la question
est-ce que le gilet jaune alors le débat
des le problème des gilets jaunes est
arrivé effectivement en partie avec le
CO2 parce que qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
? On a eu notamment une taxe carbone qui
a été mis en place dans le dans le prix
du carburant mais c'est un problème de
pétrole.
Le déclenchement des gilets jaunes,
c'est des gens qui ne peuvent plus aller
au travail parce que ça leur coûte plus
cher d'aller au travail au boulot que de
rester chez eux à rien faire. Donc c'est
ça le déclenchement. La guerre civile,
elle va être beaucoup plus rapide si
vous avez une contrainte sur le prix ou
la disponibilité de pétrole. Il suffit
de regarder ce qui se passe quand des
quand les quand les stocks de carburant
sont bloqués. En 3 jours à Paris, il y a
plus de carburant, les gens peuvent plus
aller bosser, c'est fini, ça s'arrête.
Essayer sur une île, c'est pas mal non
plus.
Non, mais par contre, tu étais quand
même un peu dur. Ou alors tu étais
vraiment sur le sujet à la fois français
et mobilité parce que tuas tu as pas que
la question du pétrole, tu as la
question du charbon ou journée si tu
sors 4,4 milliards je crois de pétrole
par an, tu sors aussi 3,9 d'équivalent
d'équivalent pétrole de charbon,
c'est-à-dire 6 ou 7 milliards de tonnes
ou plus,
je sais plus exactement les chiffres.
Enfin, c'est voilà. Et ça ça t'embarque
la question climatique. Ce que ce que
j'entends derrière l'agacement enfin moi
la manière je l'interpréterai
de manière constructive c'est de dire
arrêter de dire qu'il y a que le climat
et alors qu'il y a d'autres choses
aussi. Et oui il y a d'autres choses
aussi. Il y a des questions de
pollution. Il pleut du plastique au fin
fond des Pyrénées.
Donc il y a voilà il y a pas que les oxy
d'azote, il y a même plein d'autres
trucs. Il y a il y a des questions
effectivement sociales. Il y a des
questions de ressources, il y a des
questions d'effondrement de la
biodiversité. Celle-là c'est difficile
d'être sceptique là-dessus.
Euh voilà et donc il y a il y a un peu
tout ça en même temps à gérer et le
climat bah c'est peut-être le voilà
c'est l'éléphant dans la pièce c'est
parce que ça va ça va être peut-être
même si finalement il y a des espèces
d'acoup et que à chaque je sais pas
quoi, incendie, cyclone
virus, on convoque la question
climatique tout de suite et fait qu'au
bout d'un moment j'arrive à comprendre
que ça puisse un peu fatiguer euh
certains. Moi, par exemple, quand j'ai
vu des tribunes un peu écolo pendant le
pendant au début de de voilà de de
l'épisode sanitaire où c'était on
convoquait finalement le fait que
c'était quand même un peu le cl enfin
c'était le climat parce que c'était
climat et biodiversité qu'en fait on
avait déforesté qu'on avait poussé les
chauvsouris en dehors de leur forêt que
c'est du coup elle s'était mis mise à
mort des pangolins qui traînaient dans
dans le péri urbain et que voilà c'est
pour ça que Covid était arrivé ou alors
quand on convoquait le le père Gisol et
et qu' allait fondre et on allait voir
ce qu'on allait voir avec les virus de
pied occène. Donc moi j'ai voilà pour
moi non c'est c'était quand même c'est
une crise sanitaire qui est liée à
l'hypermobilité qu'elle lié au fait que
peut-être il y avait des marchés
d'animaux vivant des trucs bon voilà
mais donc c'est c'est toujours remettre
un peu ce truc trop trop trop peut-être
voilà peut-être qu'effectivement il faut
prendre la diversité des problèmes
environnementaux et et c'est difficile
de infiner quand même de de de laigner
dans leur globalité quoi. Alors euh
j'enchaîne sur une autre question que je
vais aussi compléter, une question de
Thomas. Que pensent-t-il de l'usure des
pneus qui produisent beaucoup de
microparticules de plastique qui se
retrouve dans l'environnement ? Alors
moi, je vais compléter les pneus et les
plaquettes de frein.
Bien sûr, il y a les pneus euh les
pneus, les plaquettes de frein et de la
route. En fait, une voiture plus elle
est lourde, d'accord, plus elle va
remettre des particules qui étaient
tombées en suspension. Et c'est pour ça
que d'ailleurs vous avez un certain
nombre d'études sérieuses sur la voiture
électrique qui disent bah si je prends
ma Renault Clio qui fait 1 tonne 2 et ma
Renault Zoée qui fait 1 tonne 5, ma
Renault Zoé Clio essence ma Renault Zoé
elle va pas avoir d'émission au pot
d'échappement mais comme elle fait 300
kg de plus elle va émettre plus de
particules en resuspension sur la route.
Alors, sachant qu'après elle va émettre
moins de particules sur les freins
puisqu'il y a du frein régénératif. Et
donc effectivement, les problèmes, il
faut toujours et c'est le problème de la
pollution, il faut les prendre dans leur
globalité. Il faut avoir une approche
systémique des problèmes et c'est pour
ça que la solution en ville à la
pollution atmosphérique, c'est pas la
voiture a priori. Alors, quand on vous
dit le vélo, on va encore vous dire
l'argument. Oui, mais les roues de vélo
et cetera. Mais sauf qu'on est un ordre
de grandeur euh qui qui n'a rien à voir
avec ça. Alors quand quand j'entends les
arguments climatoques, moi ce que je
comprends parfois quand on c'est c'est
qu'est-ce que vous venez m'emmerder avec
ma bagnole alors que euh 40 % de
l'électricité mondiale est faite au
charbon, 55 % de l'augmentation des
émissions de CO2 depuis 2000, c'est le
charbon. Bon, là-dessus, ils ont un peu
raison. On doit tout faire et c'est vrai
qu'on ne traite pas ce sujet du charbon
puisque on délocalise au moins 10 ans
environnemental et que a priori demain
si on ne fait rien toutes les voitures
électriques une grande partie sera
fabriquée en Chine. Aujourd'hui en
France vous pouvez déjà vous acheter une
voiture électrique made in China vous
pouvez déjà aller l'essayer et ça Smart
par exemple qui fabriquait ses voitures
en Moselle qui une des fiertés de la
France. On avait Smart et Toyota. Smart
ferme son usine, il l'installe en Chine
pour fabriquer des voitures électriques
qui va venir revendre chez nous. Donc ce
qu'on a fait dans l'automobile dans la
décennie 2010 où on a délocalisé toute
l'Europe de l'Ouest à l'Europe de l'Est.
Bah là, on va faire pareil, sauf qu'on
va aller directement directement en
Chine. Et le pire exemple, c'est Dacia,
hein. Dacia, la voiture lowcost faite en
Roumanie, un des pays où ça coûte le
moins cher. La voiture électrique
d'Asscia, elle va même pas être faite en
Roumanie, elle va être faite en Chine.
La Daciaia Spring que vous pourrez vous
acheter, qui est soi-disant en passant
la voiture électrique parfaite, 800 kg
hors batterie, une batterie de 27 kWh,
ça veut dire 200 km d'autonomie. Donc,
c'est adapté à l'usage du quotidien, pas
pour partir en vacances ou au ski. 800
kg euh dans mon système bonus malus,
elle aurait 4000 € de bonus en plus des
6000 €. Ben malheureusement cette
voiture elle va être fabriqué en Chine.
Et la question à 100000 dollars, c'est
comment cette voiture, petite voiture
électrique, on la fabrique pas en Chine
mais en France. question. Je refais le
lien juste une seconde un tacot, je
refais le lien avec euh avec la voiture
euh donc non mais les particules de
plastique des pneus, c'est assez marrant
parce qu'il y a une très belle étude de
l'IUCUCN qui date de quelques années.
Donc il y a 8 à 15 millions de tonnes à
l'échelle mondiale qui euh qui finissent
dans les océans juste dans les océans de
microplastique primaires. Et 35 % c'est
les pneus et la peinture routière. 35
autres % c'est les vêtements et puis il
y a un peu un reste un peu un fourto qui
s'appelle la poussière des villes. En
gros, c'est c'est l'entropie et le fait
que tout s'use un peu autour de nous et
ça finit par faire des trucs. Mais
voilà, c'est juste ça. Ça dit juste quoi
? C'està dire que la que la voiture
qu'elle soit hydrogène, qu'elle soit
électrique, qu'elle soit fabriquée ici
ou ailleurs, c'est jamais propre quoi.
C'est jamais propre. Et donc en fait
faire de l'écologie quelque part, c'est
c'est c'est faire une espèce c'est
essayer de tenter de faire une
optimisation sous contrainte.
contraintes qui sont des contraintes
hardes de de d'aspect vraiment de de
d'émission et autres et de consommation,
mais aussi des aspects euh soft enfin ou
sociaux et d'usage et autres quoi. Et
euh malheureusement voilà, il y a il y a
le mieux c'est la petite voiture pod
yaourt, ça serait ça l'idéal avec une
très petite autonomie. Et
une question pour monsieur Biwix de
Tangi. Monsieur Bwix, où on est où en
est-on de l'innovation des constructeurs
sur le réemploi depuis votre livre ? sur
les réemploi des voitures.
Alors bah pas grand chose mais alors là
je il y a il y a c'est Laurent Castagnet
qui était passé chez qui était passé ici
qui qui a une très belle une très belle
métaphore. Il dit quand vous avez votre
chaudière qui tombe en panne à la
maison, vous faites pas tomber la maison
par terre pour refaire une maison
nouvelle avec une nouvelle chaudière.
On fait tomber le plombier d'abord
[rires]
et dans les dans les voitures. C'est ce
qu'on fait quelque part quand le moteur
a atteint sa durée de vie. On met toute
la voiture en fait enfin en fait on fait
ce qu'on appelle du recyclage ou de la
valorisation. C'est-à-dire qu'on prend
on enlève les sièges, on enlève les
pare-brises, on enlève les pneus, on
enlève la batterie et on broie. Voilà,
c'est ça. Et après on fait
revalorisation.
Voilà. Oui. Alors c'est voilà, on
valorise, on on fait plein de choses.
C'est ça.
On déculpabilise.
Bah c'est une manière. Oui. Je pense que
l'économie circulaire, le fait de parler
d'économie circulaire, c'est une manière
de se dédouiner de la consommation.
Enfin, on connaît tous des gens tout à
fait euh tout à fait bons citoyens qui
font bien attention à jeter leur
bouteille en plastique dans la bonne
poubelle. En sachant pas, je pense que
peut-être allez 2 à 3 % du poids de ces
de ces bouteilles plastiques qu'ils ont
qui ont été jeté dans la poubelle
referont avec un peu de chance une
nouvelle bouteille enfin ou une partie
d'une nouvelle bouteille en plastique et
que le reste il y en aura une partie qui
sera qui sera rejetée en dans au moment
du contrôle du tri. il y en a une partie
qui va finir dans des trucs dans des
usages très différents. Enfin, ça va
traverser le monde en plus parce que on
n pas forcément les filières justement
localement de récupération. Donc la
question oui du réemploi, enfin ce que
moi je trouvais je t'entendais tout à
l'heure en trépignant un tout petit peu
mais sur le fait de relocaliser la la
production, bien sûr, on peut faire de
la relocation de production, mais la
question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on a besoin
de produire aussi ? C'estàd que infiné,
on a des nos gros sites électrointensifs
ou ou émetteur de carbone nos fourneaux
pour fabriquer de l'acier, toute une
partie de la de la de la chimie
organique pour faire tous ces polymères
et cetera. C'est c'est c'est beaucoup
infiner la voiture et puis la
construction. Voilà. Et donc pourquoi on
a besoin comme ça de de de construire
autant alors qu'effectivement on
pourrait rentrer dans une économie plus
du réemploi, de la réutilisation, de la
réparation et qui marche à toutes les
échelles pour les voitures mais qui peut
marcher même pour les villes
comme à Madagascar. Ça marche bien
Madagascar ? Non. Est-ce
ça marche au [grognement] contraire
là là en ce moment on a notre notre
leader charismatique président de la
République qui s'exprime monsieur
Emmanuel Macron.
Si vous l'aviez en face là tout de suite
maintenant, vous lui imposerez vous avez
des choses à lui imposer, à lui dire le
Nicolas.
Bah d'un point de vue pragmatique, ça
fait 3 ans 2017 presque 2 ans et demi
qu'il est au pouvoir.
3 ans et demi 3 ans et demi qu'il est au
pouvoir. Je pense qu'il a consulté tous
les Je vous ai parlé de tous les comités
théodule. il a consulté tous les gens
qui connaissaient le sujet. Il a quand
même eu Nicolas Hul qui était entre
guillemets son coût au gouvernement hein
qui a quand même tenu un peu plus d'un
an.
Euh donc,
on va dire, on va attendre qui sera le
prochain. J'ai vu quelqu'un sur votre
chaîne aujourd'hui, Albert Dupontel qui
avait un profil intéressant euh et qui
moi personnellement, je je me reconnais
dans ce qu'il dit, que c'est
[grognement] un monde la politique
malheureusement qu'on qui donne pas
envie. On n pas envie d'aller s'exposer
parce que pour faire quoi ? Pour manger
son chapeau comme Nicolas Hul, comme
Barbara Pompilier en ce moment. Barbara
Pompilli, il faut quand même savoir que
sur le bonus poids, elle a déposé il y a
un an un amendement en son nom. C'est
elle qui a déposé un amendement pour
mettre le mal sur le poids. 1 an plus
tard, elle est ministre de
l'environnement, elle est pas en mesure
de l'imposer à son gouvernement grâce à
un un beau bar de du lobby automobile.
Donc moi, je considère que je serais pas
capable de faire mieux. Donc on va on va
attendre la suite et je lui dirai non,
je lui dirais juste
je vous voir écoutez c'est dommage parce
que vous aviez une opportunité
historique de faire quelque chose et
vous n'avez rien fait.
Philippe
j'ai amené un petit papier au cas où
justement je pourrais interpeller
peut-être en direct Emmanuel Macron mais
en fait moi il m'a fait vibrer une fois
je dois l'avouer bien humblement. Alors,
c'était un peu sous contrainte aussi
dans les débuts du confinement où il
fallait arbitrer entre les pommes de
terre et l'école numérique des enfants
et puis
rou le boulot et les roules. Voilà,
exactement. Donc, il y avait un petit
côté voilà. Alors, je sais plus quelle
quelle date exact c'était, mais c'était
un moment où il commençait y avoir des
risques potentiels de défection de de la
des agents de la première ligne, que ça
soit dans les supermarchés, dans dans
les hôpitaux ou autres. Et donc il a
quand même euh euh sorti cette phrase et
je je l'ai noté pour pouvoir
effectivement euh euh voilà, c'est assez
ciselé. Il nous faudra nous rappeler que
notre pays tout entier tient sur des
femmes et des hommes que nos économies
reconnaissent et rémunèrent très mal. Et
là, il enchaîne en citant en fait la
phrase qui suit la la première phrase de
la déclaration droit de l'homme et du
citoyen de 1789. C'estàdire les hommes
naissent et demeurent libres et égau en
droit. Et juste derrière, il y a les
distinctions sociales ne peuvent être
fondées que sur l'utilité commune.
Et ensuite, il enchaîne, il faudra nous
rappeler de ce principe pour lui
redonner toute sa force. Et alors,
qu'est-ce qui est devenu ce truc ? Moi,
ça m'a fait un peu vibrer parce que je
dire, si on commence à se dire
effectivement les distinctions sociales
et les rémunérations et la
reconnaissance et cetera sont lié à
l'utilité commune, alors là ça
remettrait un certain nombre de choses
quand même à mon avis. Enfin, il y a un
beau chantier à lancer et j'en entends
plus du tout parler. Donc j'aurais été
intéressé pour ça et euh et moi il me
semble qu'en fait il est assez étonnant
Emmanuel Macron parce que je trouve
qu'il se enfin j'ai pas de leçon à lui
donner mais finalement il s'est quand
même construit euh contre le personnage
de François Hollande qui effectivement a
pas fait avait pas été forcément
formidable sur un certain promesse.
Alors non mais je j'entends quelle
promesse ?
Bah sa promesse de fermer de fermer
Fenheim.
Ah oui d'accord.
C'est quand même comme ça qu'il a été
élu. C'est c'est une des seules
promesses électorales qui était tenue.
Il faut le faut quand même le souligner
un peu mais voilà. Bon ok mais donc
disons que peut-être on a pu lui
reprocher à un moment de ce ce quinquena
d'avoir un petit peu d'immobilisme et
diffic de difficultés un peu à arbitrer
à décider et cetera et Macron il s'était
vraiment présenté comme le l'antiollande
il le revendique encore ou il revendiqué
encore. Donc moi et finalement je trouve
qu'il est un petit peu en train de de
voilà un moment finalement qui aurait pu
être qui pourrait être un moment
historique un moment où il pourrait y
avoir une logique effectivement un peu
de de courage de faire différemment
parce que il y a quand même plein de
choses qu'on qu'on pourrait faire
différemment ou qu'on a commencé à faire
différemment. Enfin, mine de rien, la
crise sanitaire, elle a elle a enfoncé
quelques tabous. Elle a enfoncé le tabou
de l'argent gratuit. Finalement, on
croyait qu'il y en avait pas. Il y en a
un. Elle a enfoncé le tabou de de la
question du déplacement. On peut arriver
le lundi au boulot sans forcément se
dire tiens, tu as fait quoi ce weekend ?
Bah rien, je suis resté chez moi. Voilà.
Bon, enfin la question du télétravail,
enfin ça y a plein de choses qui ont
bougé et finalement quel risque il
prendrait à être un petit peu plus
finalement visionnaire quoi ? parce que
là finalement on sent qu'on est un peu
dans le business as usual et quand on
essayent de se déclarer visionnaire bah
ils convoquent ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure. C'est la c'est la c'est la tech
et voilà je suis visionnaire parce que
je fais de la 5G de la Hyperloop. Ben
non, c'est pas ça d'être visionnaire.
Visionnaire c'est justement réfléchir à
à un système qui va être soutenable et
c'est certainement pas le le système de
l'accélération technologique.
Euh un couvre-feu qui commence à 21h et
qui se finit à
qui se finit à 6h du matin. Vous en
pensez quoi ?
Moi, je suis un peu un vieux donc ça va
pas me toucher, ça va pas me toucher
particulièrement et à condition que il
dure pas une décennie, je pense que
j'arriverai à le supporter de manière
personnelle. La question c'est est-ce
qu'il est est-ce qu'il est-ce qu'il est
entendable aujourd'hui ? Et est-ce queon
a vraiment les les moyens de de de
l'imposer ? Et est-ce que ça va pas
créer plus de de réaction et de dégâts
que ce que ça apporte ? J'en sais rien.
C'est c'est un peu difficile à estimer.
Mais
la la gestion de la crise sanitaire,
tu veux que je commence
?
Bah bon, d'abord c'est très difficile de
donner des leçons sur ça. Je pense qu'il
y a quand même le mode le mode panique
de la séquence de fin février début
mars.
Il a quand même des gifles à distribuer
quand même.
Alors non mais je commençais en disant
que je vais en fait c'était une
précaution d'usage pour que j' distribué
quelques gifs mais [raclement de gorge]
que infiné est-ce qu'on aurait fait
tellement mieux à place.
Oui là on parle de givf de bûcheron
quand même là qui
voilà.
Bon, ce qu'on a vu d'abord, je trouve
que c'est un assez intéressant par
rapport à des bah justement des écolos
qui convoquaient peut-être le pic de
pétrole avec derrière ça va s'effondrer
à toute vitesse. Vous allez voir ce que
vous allez voir, ça se délite très vite
dès qu'il y a des problèmes. Bah non,
dès qu'il y a des problèmes, ça se
délite pas, ça se tend. et les
États-nations ont démontré qu'ils
étaient capables de remuscler le truc
assez rapidement en disant "Je suis en
place, vous allez voir, je vais y
rester." Donc ça c'est quand même c'est
une démonstration assez fabuleuse parce
que on dire pour aller jusqu'à
l'absurdité de devoir effectivement
cocher un papier pour aller promener son
chien ou aller se les interdictions
d'aller se balader dans la forêt ou sur
la plage pour ceux qui habitaient à part
de dire bah vous allez être contraint de
la même manière que ceux qui ont pas de
plage et de forêt à proximité. Enfin, on
est quand même allé assez loin, je pense
dans l'absurde et il y aura peut-être
des trucs à écrire là-dessus. Deuxième
truc, c'est moi je trouve qu'on a été on
a été très infantilisé. C'est c'est
désagréable d'être infantilisé. On
savait déjà que depuis de Gaul que les
Français étaient des grands enfants.
Mais là, on l'a appris à nouveau. Et
finalement sur
bizarre quand c'est si bête qui nous le
dit.
Ouais. Voilà. C'est-à-dire que enfin la
séquence sur les masques qui servent à
rien puis après ça sert et puis en fait
même il est faux partout le contraire.
Alors qu'on a bon voilà, on aurait juste
pu dire bah oui, il y a une grosse
connerie qui a été faite d'ailleurs par
ailleurs, c'était pas nous hein. Donc
bon ben voilà, enfin c'était un peu les
mêmes. C'était un peu les mêmes mais pas
que. Pas complètement et en tout cas
pas. la même administration,
c'était le même genre de truc mais
voilà, on les a pas la connerie est
faite, on est là et bien allez toutes
toutes les mamies qui savent coudre, on
sort les machines les machins, on fait
du Turcell du machin, c'est ce qui s'est
une fin passé à Cuba
dans tous les pays à Bakou, ils l'ont
fait chez
a plein de pays où effectivement enfin
je veux dire moi je voilà des pays comme
le Vietnam ou autres où voilà ils sont
habitués un peu à faire leur résilience
eux-mêmes et à pas compter forcément sur
l'État et voilà les gens se sont
comportés en en adulte et je pense on
été traité en adulte alors que nous
c'était un peu un peu compliqué
là-dessus. Donc voilà, ça ça c'est pour
moi c'est un peu les deux choses les
deux choses un peu désagréable.
Peut-être la troisième aujourd'hui, je
vois dans le débat sur on referme les
restaurants, les bars, on les referme
pas. Enfin, je comprends pas que euh
alors que on a finalement nous a
expliqué assez bien sûil qu'il y avait
finalement une stratégie de on essaie de
saturer les lits d'hôpitaux mais pas
trop quoi en gros hein. Et c'est tout ce
qu'on nous a raconté, expliqué sur les
exponentiels et les 15 jours de décalage
et cetera au printemps. Bah pourquoi
finalement en sortie de confinement, on
nous a pas dit bah voilà maintenant ça
risque de revenir un peu puis de
repartir de revenir un peu et donc on va
être dans du stop and go permanent et
donc on va dire ben je comprends pas mon
café va refermer. Je comprends la
détresse économique réelle mais en fait
c'est c'est finalement si moi j'ai bien
enfin il me semble-t-il c'est la seule
stratégie qu'on a c'est c'est
effectivement d'avoir ce plateau
ondulant un peu comme le pic de pétrole
il paraît que ça serait peut-être un
plateau ondulant disent les les grandes
managers pétrolières bon voilà donc et
et que du coup bah oui à un moment il
faut fermer des trucs rouvrir refermer
et il me semble qu'on a rouvert un peu
fort parce queon voulait pas gâcher
l'été des français la reprise économique
je sais pas quoi mais version plus quoi.
Enfin, on pouvait faire un truc à 4999
euh et enfin bon avec et puis voilà,
sans masque, sans masque, sans truc. Il
y avait que dans les transports et dans
quelques trucs où on était un peu
paniqué de la saturation mais tout le
reste c'était You la boouom. Bah voilà
et puis maintenant on se retrouve à
Retropédaler. Pourquoi on n' pas réussi
à avoir ce ce ce discours et ce
programme un peu d'adulte pour se dire
voilà on va faire face au truc bah le
vaccin on va attendre un peu. Il paraît
que la fille de Poutine le teste mais
bon à part ça et et donc on va vivre un
peu avec et donc on va essayer de jouer
ce trucl et donc il y a un certain
nombre d'endroits où on va le choper.
C'est les endroits où on se balade sans
masque et on boit des bières ensemble et
et donc voilà, il y a quelques trucs qui
vont avoir plus de mal à rouvrir ou qui
vont ouvrir de manière plus
sacadé que que d'autres quoi.
Moi, je voulais revenir sur un point sur
cette crise qui rejoint un peu ce qu'on
a dit sur la France qui est toujours
tout blanc, tout noir et qui qui me
désole si on reprend les notamment
l'histoire de du docteur ou professeur
Raou. D'accord. Professeur Raou
peut-être en manque de notoriété, j'en
sais rien, mais euh qui fait une vidéo
un jour.
Cette vidéo la publie sur son compte
YouTube. Elle est reprise par les
décodeurs du monde qui disent "Fake
news, fake news" sur Facebook, elle est
désenlevée, je crois du site du
ministère fake news. Qu'est-ce que ça a
fait ? À partir de ce moment-là,
professeur Raou s'est construit en
opposition. en opposition avec le
pouvoir, en opposition avec Paris et
donc on a polarisé un débat entre les
pro Raou et les contre Raou et on a
parlé que de ça. Et aujourd'hui, on a un
petit peu changé. Maintenant, il y a les
rassuristes et il y a les alarmistes. Et
ça fait 9 mois où on met des mets un
rassuriste, un alarmiste sur le plateau,
on les jette, ils se battent entre eux
et et et qu'est-ce qu'on a fait ? On a
pas discuté, on n pas parlé de solution
et donc on est sur un débat stérile
depuis 9 mois. On n'est pas allé
regarder qu'est-ce qui se passe bien
ailleurs, quelles sont les solutions à
mettre en place. En France où les
clusters ne se font pas à l'école
et je veux dire c'est juste moi ça me ça
me ça me ça me ça me sidère. Euh et
aujourd'hui, alors oui, aujourd'hui on
prend une mesure alors qui est pas la
même mesure de qu'on a pris en mars qui
quand même moins sévère qu'en mars.
Mais estce qu'il faut savoir, moi je
j'ai fait beaucoup de dessins depuis
depuis le mois de mars puisque il se
trouve que la courbe, la fonction
logistique qu'on utilise pour une
production de pétrole, il se trouve que
pour une épidémie, on utilise aussi une
fonction logistique. Et donc, je me suis
amusé à prendre les points historiques
et à tracer une courbe qui qui répond à
l'équation de l'équation de la fraction
de logistique.
Ce qu'on voit depuis une semaine, c'est
que le Covid-19, les cas repartent dans
tous les pays et ça ça va rassurer les
Français ou pas. Mais le couvre-feu là,
on l'a annoncé pour la France mais il va
être mis en place, il est déjà mis en
place à Berlin, il va mis en place au
Pays-Bas. Le couvre-feu le couvre-feu,
vous prenez n'importe quel historien de
la santé. Il vous dira "On n'a jamais
fait un couvre-feu pour une épidémie.
On n jamais utilisé des masques cous
avec votre vieux slip pour soi-disant
faire un un filtre à particules. On voit
les gens dans la rue avec les masques un
peu de toutes les couleurs. C'est joli,
c'est machin c'est c'est sympa, ça
filtre que dalle. Alors, on nous a sorti
les masques qui ont une norme mais qui
c'est pas la norme parce que vous
comprenez. Donc les nous nous on est en
FFP2 ajusté ici, on a tous la barbe
taillée.
C'est du foutage de gueule. Le protocole
sanitaire c'est du foutage de gueule.
Vous prenez n'importe quel
épidémologiste, il faut le dira. C'est
c'est de l'hallucination totale.
Non, je pense qu' on peut pas jeter le
bébé Claudin. Il y a il y a il y a a
quelque chose qui a été fait il y a
quelque chose qui a été dit par
l'Académie des Sciences quoi ou Académie
des Sciences de médecine
euh début juillet. début juillet,
c'était il y a quand même quelques mois,
il a dit il faut porter le masque dans
tous les endroits où il interdit de
fumer. C'était très simple comme règle
parce qu'en fait la propagation du Covid
si elle est en partie aérosol, c'est un
peu comparable à quand vous fumez dans
une pièce, quand vous fumez que ça sent
fort la cigarette, vous avez besoin
d'aérer. C'était c'était facile. On
pouvait mettre ça en place début
juillet. Dès que vous êtes à un endroit
où vous avez pas le droit de fumer,
au bureau euh à l'intérieur, euh en fait
mettre un masque dehors, ça revient à
tout le monde. C'est comme si on vous
disait il faut on interdit la cigarette
parce que vous risquez de tuer votre
voisin avec votre fumé.
Voir on parle d'un aérosol qui peut se
fixer sur les surfaces avec un délai de
rémanence. Il faut il faut
bah si c'est à tout à voir quand vous
disez de porter de masque partout. Euh
un jour un jour les historiens
tragicomique, on est d'accord.
Je pense qu'il faut revenir parce qu'on
est on est quand même un peu dans
l'inconnu. C'estd que enfin dans c'est
difficile semble-t-il. Alors il y a quoi
? Il y a une étude australienne qui a
sorti il y a il y a 2 jours là sur ça
pourrait rester pendant je sais pas quoi
3 semaines sur une surface
de garder bien humide et bien dans le
noir ou je sais pas quoi ou mais c'est
vrai que du coup bah voilà là on va
aujourd'hui au restaurant c'est le
nouveau protocole c'était faut remettre
le masque entre les entre les entre les
plat
entre les bouchers
ah entre les bouchers ouais
ouais alors on va dire entre les plats
dans un premier temp moi je me suis fait
rappeler à l'ordre dans un restaurant
mais seulement entre deux plats, pas
entre deux bouchées
alors que il y a 6 mois de ça on nous
expliquait dans des vidéos très sérieuse
et compliqué que le masque fallait le
mettre une seule fois, le pincer et plus
y toucher pendant 4 heures jusqu'à ce
qu'on l'enlève parce que on allait
enlever le maître était une énorme
bêtise. Donc là maintenant on passe
notre temps dire non au contraire faut
l'enlever le maître donc on passe notre
temps à le à le toucher, à le tricoter.
Donc c'est c'est il y a un côté un peu
tragicomique qu'il faut reconnaître.
Bon, ce qui ce qui est pas tragicomique,
c'est le fait que heureusement, il y a
un profil de létalité qui voilà
globalement et et statistiquement
malheureusement sur des gens fragiles et
âgés et que si j'ose même pas j'ose pas
imaginer si on avait eu ce ce côté un
peu tragicomique mais sur un virus qui
aurait pu taper de manière un peu un peu
aléatoire sur toutes les clasages et là
on aurait eu des défections massives, on
aurait eu tous les plans pandémie
auraient sauté même dans les centrales
nucléaires. Juste nu de la chance par
rapport à ça.
Non, les centrales nucléaires pour avoir
été en contact
de l'épidémie, on était en contact avec
des gens qui bossaient dans les
centrales nucléaires qui la plupart la
plupart ont vraiment géré le truc. On
était très très fier de de deil
y en a qui s'enfermai avec les lit camp
de la bouffe.
Ils ont géré le truc les enf Nicolas
Millon. Non, juste pour finir, je vous
disais les débats blanc et blanc et
noir, pro raou, antiraou, euh rassurer
et
on est quand même en train de vivre une
crise qui est bien pire que celle de
2009, qui va ravager l'économie,
qui va mettre des millions d'emplois de
gens au chômage, qui va mettre des
beaucoup d'entreprises en faillite.
C'est un sujet sérieux et ultra
structurant pour l'avenir de la France.
Ça mérite peut-être un tout petit peu
mieux que ces débats stériles d'où rien
ne ressort. C'est un projet où on
pourrait, on s'est rendu compte qu'on
était capable de faire de la sobriété.
C'était l'exemple typique de la
sobriété. On se déplace moins, on voit
moins loin et et tout diminue. La
pollution diminue, l'empreinte de
carbone diminue. On sait faire peut-être
pas tout le temps, tous les jours, mais
on est capable de faire. Ça aurait pu
être l'opportunité de construire avec
tout le monde en société un véritable
projet. Et là, qu'est-ce qu'on a ? On a
juste des ans qui s'opposent. On a un
Paris-Marseille, PSG Marseille qui n'en
finit plus. On en est la 10e mi-temps et
à un moment donné, il faut siffler, il
faut siffler la fin.
Attendez, attendez, il faut que je vous
lise la En direct Covid-19, un
couvre-feu instauré en Île-de-France et
8 métropoles annoncent Macron
à partir de ce soir ou pas ?
Voilà, c'est magnifique.
À partir de quand du coup ?
J'ai pas lu c'est à partir de samedi 17.
Non mais on est quand même dirigé par
une belle brochette de connard. Je suis
Non, je suis désolé mais il se passe
quelque chose et c'est pour ça qu'on
entend moins le professeur Raoul depuis
une semaine. Il est il a dit un peu
dépité en parlant dans sa barbe sur ses
news, j'ai l'impression qu'il y a un
nouveau mutant plus virulent. Euh quand
on regarde les chiffres en Italie, en
Allemagne, aux Pays-Bas, en Angleterre,
en Belgique, en Espagne, en France,
c'est exactement le même schéma depuis
une semaine partout. Ce que je vais vous
dire, c'est que ces mesures-là, elles
vont être prises dans tous ces pays dans
les jours qui viennent. Dans les jours
qui viennent. Et ce trucl va pas durer
malheureusement. On va oui, on va devoir
restreindre nos libertés jusque jusque
probablement la fin du mois de mars. Il
faut être voilà, c'est les c'est les
maladies comme la grippe respiratoire
d'hiver. On va être restreint mais il
faut surtout il faut surtout qu'on
prépare la suite parce que on va on va
on va arriver sur un champ de ruine. On
va arriver sur un champ de ruine.
Alarmiste marrant. Enfin, on a
exactement la même question sur la
question et en fait même depuis les
années 50 euh c'est les les corps
nuucopien le bonheur par la technologie
et puis les lanceurs de l'alerte écolo.
Et effectivement tu on narrive pas à
faire émerger quelque chose de de
d'intelligent.
Vous parlez dans le micro.
Ah pardon. Oui de tourner.
On on arrive à la fin de notre
interview. Je vais vous demander trois
bouquins et un conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
Ou là là, c'est je vais commencer sur
les bouquins, ça sera plus facile. C'est
assez classique.
Moi, ma Bible c'est Limits to Gross, le
rapport du club de d'Europe. Donc si
vous l'avez pas lu, je vous le
conseille. Vous pouvez lire l'adaptation
en français d'ailleurs, enfin la
traduction en français avec une préface
de Jean-Marc Jeankovici. Euh c'est ça
vous donne les bases. Euh le second euh
c'est un peu la suite de ce livre-là qui
a été écrit par Philippe Biwix, euh
c'est l'âge des Amiches qui l'a renommé
l'âge des lots. Euh et donc ça c'est
intéressant parce que le pour moi euh
le le rapport du club d'Europe Limite
Sougos faisait un constat
mais n'apportait pas de solution.
Euh et le livre de Philippe l'âge des
lots apporte des solutions. Comment
est-ce qu'on fait dans un monde fini
avec moins de ressources, avec un monde
postcroissance, plein d'emploi ? Alors
Philippe parlera mieux que moi. Ça c'est
un second livre important. Et le troisè,
bon, pour ceux qui aiment l'énergie, je
le recommanderai peut-être un livre de
Mathieu Oxano qui s'appelle l'or noir
sur le pétrole qui a un petit pavé mais
qui est très intéressant pour bien
comprendre comment ça marche.
Et le conseil
Ah,
le conseil c'est après non ?
Ah c'est après. D'accord. Trois
bouquins. Moi je suis embêté parce que
moi ça fait 3 x 15 3 x 5 là. Du coup je
je vais je vais répéter sans doute des
bouquins que j'ai déjà répété. Donc un
seul
euh
allez relire un un classique Ivanic
énergie et équité voilà sur la question
de voilà ce ce le fait que
que si on prend la voilà on peut
calculer une vitesse généralisée qui
inclut les heures qu'on a passé à se
payer sa voiture et que quand on intègre
ça finalement le vélo est bien plus bien
plus efficace par exemple et quelques
autres belles considérations
pour attendre le conseil aux jeunes
génération de Nicolas.
Je vais lire un tweet que la communauté
nous a envoyé. Ça a dit "Ne sortez pas
de chez vous mais allez travailler. Ne
faites pas la fête mais envoyez vos
enfants à l'école mais restez chez vous
mais partez en vacances.
C'est très beau. C'est
en même temps.
Allez, du coup un bouquin, ça me fait
venir un bouquin. La politique de
l'Oxymor de Bertram et ça avait été vu
comme un brûlot antisarcosis parce que
c'est la question de l'Oximor en fait.
On passe notre temps en fait à vivre
dans un dans un monde où on est en
injonction contradictoire et voilà,
c'est un petit opus qui doit dater de
2009 de mémoire et qui est très sympa.
Nicolas Millant, un conseil pour les
jeunes générations.
Moi, je vais terminer sur mon sur mes
couleurs, mon blanc et noir, mes 50
nuances de gris.
Le monde est jamais tout blanc et jamais
tout noir. Donc enseignez-vous, essayez
de voir où sont les nuances sur chacun
des sujets. Essayz de c'est avec des
gens qui se renseignent, qui sont qui
connaissent bien ces sujets là, qu'on va
aller rentrer dans des nuances de gris
et qu'on va pouvoir faire avancer le
débat. et la France est un pays qui est
enfermé aujourd'hui dans le blanc et le
noir.
Philippe, un conseil
un conseil c'est la Ha je crois qui me
disait plus ou moins le le chemin est
plus important que la cible quoi. Donc
voilà on est sur un chemin. La cible
elle est très difficile à définir, elle
est mouvante, elle est compliquée. Donc
parlons-nous, essayons d'agir,
d'avancer, d'avoir ce débat là
effectivement et et prenons du plaisir
dedans. Enfin, c'est c'est absolument
indispensable. C'est nécessaire. On peut
pas se flageller pendant 40 ans sur le
fait que les océans vont monter en 2100
et après et il faut trouver du plaisir
dans l'action. L'important n'est pas la
destination mais le chemin. Messieurs,
merci.
Merci. Bonsoir.
Merci. Bon couvre-feu.
[musique]